Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen, Timpen.
Warum habe ich jetzt hier wieder keinen Empfang?
Ich würde schätzen, die Errichtung einer Mobilfunkzelle ist aus rechtlichen Gründen leider nicht möglich.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 451 vom 23.01.23,
23.1.23, wie nennt man das? Wenn so ein Datum in die eine Richtung wie in die andere Richtung funktioniert und man ein bisschen cheatet,
weil ja eigentlich noch eine 20 dazugehört, aber man die jetzt weglässt, weil dann hat man nichts mehr worüber man reden kann.
Ist so ein Vexierbild. Nein, das ist kein Vexierbild. Man sieht ja immer das Gleiche, nicht zwei Dinge in einem.
Ein Vexierbild ist mehr so der Blick, wenn man so auf die deutsche Politik schaut. Das sind dann immer so zwei Bilder auf einmal, die einem entgegenkommen.
Ja, so sieht es aus. Auf jeden Fall machen wir wieder eine Sendung.
Mir fällt nur auf, 23 ist eine Primzahl, 1 ist eine Primzahl.
Und wenn man 23 plus 23 plus 1 rechnet, ist 47 auch eine Primzahl. Und die Quersumme von 47 ist 11, das ist auch eine Primzahl.
Das ist auch eine Primzahl. Oh Gott.
Wahnsinn. Ist zwei ja eigentlich auch eine Primzahl? Das ist interessant. Die Frage ist, was bedeutet das alles? Genau, wir starten nämlich LNP Prime, da kriegt ihr eure Informationen ohne zusätzlichen Versandaufschlag.
2 ist auch eine Primzahl. Also die Quersumme von 11, 2 ist auch wieder eine Primzahl.
Heute ist einfach Prime Day.
Und eins, zwei und drei, alle Zahlen, aus denen das Datum ist, Prima-Zahlen.
Mein Hirn splattert gerade durchs Studio. Wahnsinn. Einfach.
Boah.
Unglaublich.
Und? 2023 wird der CCC 42.
Das ist in der Tat schon länger auf meiner Liste. Jetzt kommt endlich was zusammengehört.
Es macht alles Sinn.
Ja genau und wenn ihr jetzt diese Aufzeichnung rückwärts hört, dann wisst ihr schon.
Kuhibono.
Okay, lass mal.
Dann glaubt ihr, dass wir da alles überhaupt keinen Sinn machen, wenn ihr die Rückwärtswerte A wahr, wenn ihr die oft genug Rückwärtswerte hat und dabei die richtigen
Substanzen zu euch nehmt, dann verspreche ich euch, wird es irgendwann Sinn machen.
Aber da muss man richtig, richtig.
Also ich glaube mit diesen ganzen Substanzen wird das ganze schwierig und dann ist es leider
Unavailable for Legal Reasons.
Genau, heute ist nämlich wieder soweit.
Der HTTP-Status ist wieder zurück. Zumindest die offiziellen Zahlen passen jetzt mal wieder hier zu unserer Episodenausgabe.
Und lange schon erwartet, beigesehen fast schon, 451 Unavailable for Legal Reasons ist nicht nur ein ganz besonderer Fehlercode, das ist auch, glaube ich, der jüngste, der so beschlossen wurde.
Und 451, Primzai, ja, nein?
Ich vermute ja. Echt? Das ist unglaublich. Jetzt macht alles keinen Sinn mehr. Genau, 451. Also das auch so ein Fehlercode und der ist halt eingeführt worden vor ein paar Jahren, weil sich eben im.
Nein, 11 mal 41 ist 451.
Internet das in zunehmendem Maße so entwickelt hat, dass bestimmte Dinge nicht vielleicht deshalb nicht erreichbar sind, weil der Server down ist oder man die URL falsch eingetippt hat oder sonst irgendwas technisches vorgefallen ist. Da hat einfach einer abgescheitert gesagt,
geht nicht. Stoppschild ins Internet gepackt und gesagt, hier geht es nicht weiter. Und da das immer
sehr unangenehm ist, wenn irgendwo so eine Zensur ausgeübt wird, dachte sich das Web-Konsortium,
wenn es schon so weit ist, dann sollte man es zumindest auch klar signalisieren und hat dann diesen Fehlercode eingeführt. Und das natürlich nicht so ganz ohne Hintergedanken,
weil natürlich die 451 so eine Referenz ist auf den Roman Fahrenheit 451, der so ein dystopischer
Roman ist von Ray Bradbury und der sozusagen von so einer dystopischen Welt spielt, wo Bücher
verbrannt werden. Das hat alles auch so ein bisschen mit seinen eigenen Erlebnissen zu tun. Als er in Deutschland war, Bücher verbrannt wurden etc. Darauf bezieht sich das alles und den Titel,
hat er so gewählt, weil er meinte, dass bei Fahrenheit 451 die Temperatur
erreicht sei, wo sich Papier selbst entzündet.
Also, klassischer Ami, der sich einer internationalen Quelle bedient.
Ist schön gedacht, stimmt leider nur nicht, aber es ist wohl schon so, dass ungefähr bei 451 Grad Celsius das stattfindet.
431. Leckow Funny. Krass.
Klang halt einfach besser. So, ja. Naja, aber es zählt ja das Signal und das ist
eigentlich relativ deutlich ausgesendet worden. Ja und dementsprechend haben wir,
jetzt diesen Fehlerkurs. Ich weiß nicht ob du schon mal in den gelaufen bist. Ich kann mich ehrlich gesagt nicht so richtig daran erinnern, das schon mal gehabt zu haben bis auch nicht ausschließen.
Ich glaube, ich weiß, dass wir seine Einführung damals auch in der Sendung begleitet haben.
Und ich meine, dass das jetzt auch nicht so unbedingt ernst gemeint war, dieser Vorschlag.
Das ist jetzt nicht so mit, hey, geile Idee, sondern eher auch mit, ey, scheiße, das nimmt
überhand. Jetzt könnten wir halt einen Status-Code machen, der dann im Prinzip so ein bisschen, also de facto ist es ja etwas, der Status-Code wird ja eigentlich von deinem Server gewürfelt,
das heißt, es wäre jetzt irgendwie so was wie, oh, du scheinst aus der Europäischen
zu kommen und aus legalen Gründen können wir dir diesen Inhalt nicht zugänglich machen.
Es gibt auch bei Wikipedia ist das schöne Example, wo die römische Provinz von Judea aufgrund des,
Lex Julia Majestates den Zugang zu Ressourcen der Volksfront von Judea verbietet.
Der Status Code wird ja üblicherweise zumindest in einer Ende-zu-Ende-HTTPS-verschlüsselten,
Welt, würdest du den selber setzen müssen, dann wäre es eben, ja, okay, wir dürfen diesen Inhalt, den wir hier machen, eben müssen wir für dieses oder jenes Land nicht
ermöglichen, aus diesem Grund sperren wir das oder so. Aber ja, ich habe ihn jetzt, ich wüsste auch nicht.
Sicherlich wird ihn irgendwo jemand schon mal angewendet haben.
Zumindest als Witz.
An HTTP Status Code to Report Legal Obstacles. Genau, das ist ja auch der Hintergrund hier, zu sagen, wir, also das ist der Status Code,
und wir geben dir jetzt auch die Information darüber, dass es hier irgendeine Zensur, eine Zensur gibt und wir machen nicht irgendwie einen 404, um dir den Eindruck zu vermitteln,
diesen Inhalt gäbe es nicht, sondern wir sagen, den Inhalt gibt es. Aber es gibt rechtliche Hürden,
die uns daran hindern, Indie zugänglich zu machen.
Also umso länger ich darüber nachdenke, umso eher könnte ich mir das vorstellen, dass der Code auch wirklich zum Einsatz kommt, weil man denkt natürlich jetzt zuerst erstmal so mit der Staat, der wird ja schon...
Also was weiß ich, in Russland hat man andere Methoden Informationen platt zu machen, da kommt dann keiner und fragt freundlich nach dem richtigen Status Code. wenn so intermediäre, so Caching Sites und so etwas in irgendeiner Form dann durch solche,
legalen Gründe dazu gezwungen werden, etwas zu sperren, dann ist es ja wiederum in ihrem Interesse, da auch den Blame woanders hinzuschieben. Und von daher kann ich mir das durchaus vorstellen, dass der zum Einsatz kommt, aber ich kann mich jetzt nicht konkret dran erinnern.
Vorgeschlagen wurde der vor zehn Jahren, also vor 2012 und dann 2015 angenommen.
Ja, wir haben es auf jeden Fall behandelt damals. Und eine kurze Korrektur, ich habe das Beispiel von der Wikipedia zitiert, aber dieses Beispiel ist sogar in dem echten RFC 77025 drin.
MultiPython ist tief verwurstelt in der Internetkultur, das kann man sagen.
Also es ist das Originalbeispiel, nicht ein Wikipedia-Beispiel.
So, dann. Ah, der Merch-Versand findet statt, habe ich festgestellt durch Twitter.
Da haben Leute mir schöne Fotos geschickt von schönen Hoodies und T-Shirts, die ich.
Echt? Dir? Oder uns?
Selber noch nicht habe. Muss ich jetzt auch mal.
Also das findet jetzt statt. Wir haben ja immer darauf hingewiesen, dass man da mit Wartezeiten,
leider rechnen muss, vor allem mit Wartezeiten aufgrund der Weihnachtszeit, so dass es jetzt
nicht mehr zu erwarten war, dass ihr das vor Weihnachten bekommt, aber jetzt wird es,
ausgeliefert und die Leute freuen sich. Ein schönes Motiv. Ich freue mich auch, möchte
das auch haben. Kommt. Ach so, und vielleicht noch kurzer Hinweis, wenn ihr Fragen habt.
Kommt.
Bitte nicht an uns stellen, weil wir haben tatsächlich damit nichts zu tun. Das wird alles von Ticket-Toaster gemacht, deswegen müsst ihr euch beifragen zu eurem Versand,
zu Sonderanfertigung. Ich will aber 5xS oder so, das müsst ihr dann alles leider mit Ticket-Toaster,
erklären oder zum Glück, weil dafür werden sie bezahlt.
Okay, dann hatten wir ein Feedback und jetzt bin ich, ich hoffe, ich wiederhole das.
Ich mache das ganz schnell. Wir hatten vor mehreren Sendungen darüber gesprochen, dass in Deutschland der Notruf ohne SIM-Karte nicht mehr möglich ist, obwohl er es ursprünglich war.
Und dazu haben wir dann gesagt, da habe ich mich beklagt, dass es irgendwie, oder habe
der Grund dafür ist, dass es zu viel Missbrauch gab. Da habe ich mir gefragt, wie blöd sind denn die Leute? Und dann haben wir eigentlich eine E-Mail bekommen von Stefan.
Und ich hoffe, ich wiederhole das jetzt nicht. Hintergrund ist offiziell der Missbrauch der Notruffunktion. Zum großen Teil von Flohmärkten,
auf denen die Funktionsfähigkeit von Handys damit geprüft und demonstriert wurde, dass bei den Notrufen fehlt.
Und dadurch gab es dann an Samst und Sonntagen,
eine Flut von Anrufen bei den Notrufzentralen. Okay, so weit der Hinweis, kann ich mir vorstellen, dass das stimmt. Das ist die einzige Nummer, die man eben ohne SIM anrufen kann, aber auch wirklich...
Die Leute, weißt du? Die Leute, so sind sie.
Du machst ihnen einen schönen Notruf und sagen, ja geil, kann ich mein Handy darin ausprobieren.
Was willst du mit solchen Leuten machen?
Aber das ist das, warum wir nicht gute Dinge haben.
Das ist das, warum wir keine erste Aide haben.
Ich stelle mir die Frage, ob hier...
Wir waren ja auch so ein bisschen zu dem Ergebnis gekommen, dass es jetzt tatsächlich in der heutigen Zeit
wirklich nur noch sehr selten ist, dass man jetzt ein Telefon, ein Mobiltelefon, sich in zwar geladenem
Zustand befindet, aber ohne SIM-Karte. Insofern ist es wahrscheinlich halbwegs verschmerzbar,
dass es diese Möglichkeit nicht gibt. Also, wenn jetzt wenig Menschen daran sterben. Aber ja, gut.
Es ist ja ich meine mittlerweile sind natürlich einfach Mobilfunktelefone,
überall so und ich glaube der Fall dass irgendwo ein Mobilfunktelefon ohne funktionierende SIM-Karte,
gerade die einzige Option ist mit der man einen Notruf auslösen kann ich glaube das ist dann doch sehr überschaubar so und wenn dann halt einfach,
da so ein ja so so ein übergriffiges Verhalten im Wesentlichen das einzige ist was man da noch messen kann durch die Bereitstellung dieses Features, kann man auch schon vorstellen,
warum man das irgendwie einstellt. Das ist aber auch wirklich so ein Punkt, da werde ich dann auch gefühlt alt, so dieser Umgang mit so öffentlichem Gut, das ist ja dann auch so ein bisschen so wie zerstörte Bushaltestelle, da stehe ich dann schon da und denke mir so,
Also früher hat es das nicht gegeben.
Das hat es wahrscheinlich früher auch gegeben, aber man denkt das ja dann immer.
Hat es früher auch gegeben.
Die müssen einfach dem System zeigen, die müssen dem System so richtig einen auswischen. Und dann hauen die halt die Scheibe von der Bushaltestelle kaputt und treten Elektroroller um.
Und machen damit so richtig mal, weißt du, zeigen mal so richtig, was hier los ist.
Ist, wer hier die neue Generation ist, wer dieser Welt noch Veränderungen herbeiführen kann und dem System mal so richtig einen auswischt, dann kannst du dieser Rebellion, die da drin steckt,
ja auch diese Männlichkeit, die dadurch demonstriert werden kann, das darfst du nicht
nicht unterschätzen, wie beeindruckend das auch ist für die jungen Mädels.
Wenn da mal so einer eine Bushaltestelle kaputt klopft, die denken sich ja, meine Güte, muss
der erzeugungsfähig sein. Kannst du dir ja vorstellen, das siehst du doch überall.
Da muss ich jetzt unbedingt meine Chromosome hintragen.
Am Ende funktioniert das sogar.
Da muss ich jetzt, von dem will ich eine Teenager-Schwangerschaft.
Das ist das einzige, was dann am Ende funktioniert.
Man weiß es nicht.
Man weiß es nicht. Ja, also das ist, ja.
Nein, das ist dramatisch. Es ist wirklich... Oh je.
Das alte Selektionsprinzip scheint so ein bisschen ausgedient zu haben.
Mit The Fittest hat irgendwie echt schlechte Karten.
Ohje, okay.
Kommen wir zu einer übergeordneten Frage. ausgelöst durch die ganze Aufregung rund um die neuen AI-basierten Systeme,
die pfiffige Sachen ausspucken.
Angefangen hatte es ja mit den Bildern und das ist auch noch das sichtbarste, auch wenn jetzt gerade viel Diskussion um Text entstanden ist durch Chat-GPT,
Gab es ja vorher eben schon so Dolly, Mid Journey, Stable Diffusion und sicherlich ja noch ein paar andere Player, daran haben wir jetzt gerade nicht einfallen.
Also Start-ups, Open Source Projekte, die von den Fortschritten der KI-Technologie und speziell eben das Machine Learning profitieren und dann eben in der Lage sind,
jetzt neue Werke zu schaffen. Ich wähle jetzt schon meine Worte mit Bedacht, weil das jetzt nicht,
ganz unerheblich ist. Und gerade im Bildbereich, wenn man sich halt anschaut, wie so die Software
dann auf einen zukommt, ist es ja so, dass man dort eben hingehen kann, mit Text sagen kann, ich hätte gern jetzt mal ein Bild, da ist was weiß ich, Space Invaders mit Kaogumi im Mund,
die Masayessing. Das setzen die Dinger dann halt in irgendeiner Form in Bildmaterial um, ob das dann was taugt oder nicht.
Und dann kann man aber auch noch so Optionen angeben und sagen, jetzt hätte ich das ganz gerne, aber auch noch so als wäre es von Rembrandt gemalt. Oder mit einem Einfluss von Andy Warhol, sprich hier wurde dann auch gleich so diese Anleihe an einen spezifischen Stil mit eingebaut.
Und was natürlich auch noch eine große Rolle spielt, ist, dass diese Systeme dadurch trainiert werden, indem sie sich erstmal Sachen anschauen, auf denen die eigentlichen Objekte und auch
Stilrichtungen klar sind.
Also Bilddatenbanken, wo man eben die Software drauf werfen kann, sagen kann, hier guck dir das mal an.
Und übrigens bei diesen Bildern kann ich dir auch genau sagen, was da drauf ist.
Weil dieser Bezug zu dem Text, zu dem Inhalt muss ja auch erstmal irgendwo herkommen.
Den denkt sich die Software nicht selber aus. Das hat alles erstmal was mit so Ground Truth zu tun. So funktioniert Machine Learning generell.
Und richtige Intelligenz werden wir erst haben, wenn das nicht erforderlich ist.
Jetzt geht natürlich die Sache in die nächste Runde,
Weil natürlich viele aufmerksam geworden sind im künstlerischen Bereich.
Die sagen so, wie was, ihr guckt uns hier unsere Bilder an und ihr macht dann da ein
Produkt draus, wo dann vielleicht Leute Geld für bezahlen und wir kriegen mal wieder nichts ab.
Ist denn das überhaupt mit dem Urheberrecht oder ist denn das überhaupt mit dem Copyright vereinbar?
Vereinbar. Und es gab jetzt schon Künstler, die auf Basis von Urheberrecht Startups verklagt haben und auch Getty Images ist jetzt hier mit dabei und,
sagt, Leute, ihr könnt hier einfach unsere Bilddatenbanken nehmen und die,
einfach mal so auslesen und dann da eure Modelle draus bauen und dann habt ihr was und wir kriegen da nichts von ab. Und das ist natürlich jetzt wirklich,
eine interessante Frage, wie man das bewertet.
Ja, also schwierig.
Irgendwie scheint das so ein Gesetz der großen Zahlgeschichte zu sein. Weil jetzt, wenn du in deinem Leben so und so viele Fotos gemacht hast, so und so viele
Bilder gemalt hast, dann könnte man ja theoretisch oder überhaupt, wenn man das Lehrmaterial der AI kennen würde, könnte man ja ungefähr schauen, wie viel Beitrag du jetzt geleistet
hast. Und der wird natürlich als Einzelperson verschwindend gering sein. Also warum sollten
die dir etwas geben, wenn die Entfernung deines Beitrags aus dem Lehrmaterial am Ende garantiert,
keinen Effekt, also einen nicht messbaren Effekt auf die Qualität dieses AI-Produktes hat.
Also wie viel wird es jetzt haben? Ja, hier ist ein Bruchteil eines Cent.
Gleichzeitig, wenn das Material, was Sie als Lehrmaterial haben, in der Summe,
Daraus schöpfen sie natürlich enormen Gewinn oder enorme Möglichkeiten, die sie sonst nicht hätten. Und sie nutzen dieses Material ohne jegliches in gewisser Maße erklärtes Nutzungsrecht.
Also es ist wirklich ein spannendes Feld, ne?
Es ist wirklich ein spannendes Feld. Was ja nicht stattfindet, ist die unmittelbare Reproduktion.
Und hier wird es auch nochmal interessant in rechtlicher Hinsicht.
Wir haben ja nun in Deutschland eine etwas andere Gesetzgebung. Hier haben wir das Urheberrecht. Das heißt, hier liegt ein Recht beim Urheber, das Werk, was der Urheber, die Urheberin, geschaffen hat, als solche weiter zu verwenden.
Man kann dann Nutzungsrechte abtreten, aber es gilt erst mal das Urheberrecht. Im angelsächsischen Rechtsraum ist halt das Copyright das definierende Element.
Da geht es eigentlich von vornherein um die Vervielfältigung.
Jetzt findet ja eine Vervielfältigung in dem Sinne gar nicht statt. Und auch eine Wiedergabe des Originals in dem Sinne nicht.
Weil jetzt auf einmal eine Nutzung vorliegt, die so bisher noch keiner auf dem Zettel hatte. Also ich meine, es ist ja auch nicht so, dass wenn du jetzt in eine Galerie gehst oder dir die Fotos anschaust und dich davon inspirieren lässt,
dass dann dafür eine Lizenz gebürtfällig wird.
Und man könnte argumentieren, dass das, was diese Algorithmen machen, ja nur ein sehr genaues Hinschauen und selbst Inspirieren auf Basis mathematischer Vorgänge ist.
Wo steht Inspiration in irgendeiner Form eine weiterreichbare Dienstleistung ist, die in irgendeiner Form entlohnt werden muss.
Jetzt kann man natürlich bei sowas wie Getty Images sagen, die Nutzung dieser Datenbank ist natürlich für euch extrem wertvoll, weil das alle Anforderungen erfüllt.
Also erstmal die Fotos haben eine gewisse Qualität. Gut, das mag jetzt nicht so das Wichtigste sein, weil auch aus verschwommenen Sachen kann man letzten Endes Informationen gewinnen, aber es ist natürlich schonmal sehr gut.
Wenn du jetzt sagst, gib mir mal Bilder mit Füchsen, ja, und dann kriegst du wirklich eine breite Zahl an Füchsen in allen Farbtönerungen und über alle Kontinente verteilt, alle Varianten
von Füchsen in tausend verschiedenen Darstellungen. Und du kriegst nicht nur die Bilder mit den Füchsen, sondern du kriegst auch noch die
Information mit dem Bild, dass da ein Fuchs drauf ist. Das ist natürlich für Trainingsmaterial hervorragend. Also insofern liegt hier tatsächlich auch eine Leistung vor, weil diese Datenbank quasi
für deine Trainingszwecke wunderbar geeignet ist. Und wenn du die dann eben dafür einsetzen möchtest, dann könnte das eben durchaus
ein Mehrwert darstellen. was den Urheber betrifft, der jetzt dieses Foto gemacht hat, wird es dann schon ein
bisschen schwieriger, weil kommt jetzt die Bildbeschreibung von dem Urheber?
Eigentlich nicht, das macht dann wahrscheinlich irgendjemand anders,
guckt auf das Foto drauf und sagt ja okay, da ist jetzt das und das und das drin zu sehen und ich habe das jetzt immer ordentlich verteckt.
Und daraus stellt sich einfach generell natürlich jetzt die Frage, inwiefern sind solche Ansprüche überhaupt gerechtfertigt und wenn ja, auf Basis welcher Rechtsauffassung,
Rechtsgebung und welcher Gesetze ist es, das oder nicht.
Also ich kann da noch nicht mal so eine... also auf jeden Fall, sage ich mal, so das Minimum wäre ja,
dass das jetzt Teil deines Urheberrechtes wird, dass du zumindest bestimmen kannst, ob du möchtest oder nicht möchtest, dass eine derartige Nutzung deiner Materialien stattfindet oder nicht.
Also du sagst hier, pass auf, ich habe dieses Bild gemalt, das ist super, das gefällt mir. Da stelle ich hier, sagen wir mal, Creative Commons zur Verfügung, aber da darf keine AI
mittrainiert werden. So würde ich jetzt schon, also dass du damit leben musst, dass jemand,
weil du etwas ins Internet gestellt hast, eine AI damit füttert, kann ja auch nicht richtig sein. Zumal ja EIs auch für andere Zwecke gefüttert werden. Also vielleicht gar nicht künstlerische
und Reproduktionszwecke.
Ja, man kann natürlich alle möglichen Nutzungen haben, nur, dann könnte man argumentieren,
wenn du nicht möchtest, dass man auf das Bild schaut und sich seine eigenen Gedanken dazu macht,
dann darfst du es halt auch nicht veröffentlichen. Also es war ja in dem Moment auch eine bewusste Entscheidung, es zu veröffentlichen und damit ist es ja in der Öffentlichkeit. Und bestimmte Rechte sind halt vorbehalten.
Vielleicht auch manche, some or all rights reserved.
Und es kann aber auch dann sozusagen, ja, kann aber auch sein, okay, dann könntest du aber auch deinen Anteil haben, aber wie willst du diesen Anteil quantifizieren, hast du ja auch schon gesagt, ne?
Ist total schwierig das jetzt in irgendeiner Form zu machen, zumal es ja auch schwer zurückzufinden ist.
Ich meine, es gibt eine Ausnahme und da gab es, glaube ich, jetzt zumindest bei, ich weiß nicht, war das jetzt Dali oder Stable Diffusion,
auch schon so eine Einigung mit irgendwelchen Künstlern, weil in dem Moment, wo du sagst, okay, ich stelle dir jetzt explizit eine Funktion bereit, die dein Bild so aussehen lässt im Stil,
von. So und jetzt insert your favorite artist. Ja, also was weiß ich, ich möchte gern, dass,
was weiß ich, die Mainzelmännchen so aussehen, als wären sie jetzt von Banksy gezeichnet worden.
Wer hat da mehr dagegen und wer wird als erstes oder entspannt?
Das Werbeschwerz nicht als erstes.
Also sowohl was jetzt so Romanzelmännchen betrifft als auch Banksy, ist schon mal eine Frage, ist das jetzt irgendeiner Form der...
Ich meine, es gab natürlich auch schon bisher Künstler, die ähnliche Dinge gemacht haben.
Es wird sicherlich irgendjemand, wird schon mal was Meinzelmännchenartiges gemacht haben, wo du sofort siehst, das ist irgendwie Meinzelmännchen, aber auch irgendwie nicht.
So. Na, als er irgendwie inspiriert hat, Zipfelmütze sehen dann irgendwie so aus wie Ganoven und so.
Und niemand würde jetzt auf die Idee kommen, dass man jetzt, weil man so etwas Ähnliches wie Meinzelmännchen gemalt hat,
die aber vollkommen anders aussehen als Meinzelmännchen, dass dann in irgendeiner Form eine Lizenzzahlung erforderlich wäre. Also bei einem normalen Künstler.
In dem Moment, wo es eine Maschine ist, soll das dann auf einmal gelten? Was ist da der Unterschied, wenn das jemand programmiert?
Programmierung ist ja am Ende auch eine künstlerische Leistung,
und die basiert nur auf einer anderen Methode.
Bei dem einen geht es halt einfach so im Kopf vor und bei dem anderen halt auf Maschinen. Na gut, aber das Ergebnis ist dasselbe.
Ist wirklich sehr sehr sehr schwer zu beantworten.
Aber mir klingeln natürlich jetzt schon so die Alarmglocken, weil wenn jetzt die Bilddatenbanken,
und die Urheber, die Fotografen entsprechend Überlegungen anstellen,
dann kann sie die Uhr danach stellen, dass die Musikindustrie schon an Deporters ist.
Ja, genau. Verwertungsgesellschaft. Die GEMA steht dann da.
Oh, da kommen viele. Und bei Bildern stehen ja auch dann irgendwelche. Dann kommen die Abmarner. Also das.
Ja, also ich meine Musik, ich weiß nicht, ob ich jetzt nur den Markt nicht überblicke und die Dinger gibt's schon oder hast du schon davon gehört?
Also gibt es natürlich so Musik, AI-basierte Musikgeneratoren habe ich schon gesehen. nur.
Ich habe übrigens hier, kann ich mal angeben, die zehnte Sinfonie von Beethoven, die zehnte
hat er nicht fertig gemacht, nicht fertig gekriegt. Da gab es dann so...
Da hast du die fertig gemacht oder.
Ne, das hatte so eine AI. Da haben die eine AI damit gefüttert und das wurde aufgeführt
in der Elbphilharmonie. Da war ich, da habe ich mir angeguckt, angehört.
Und da haben sich sehr viele dran beschäftigt mit dieser zehnten Sinfonie von Beethoven.
Unter anderem haben die auch dann Komponisten und so. Und Beethoven, Kenner Beethoven, hat ja sein eigenes,
der ist im Prinzip seine eigene musikwissenschaftliche Gattung, wo dann Leute, die jetzt, was weiß ich,
Leute, die können halt jedes Beethovenstück spielen und haben den studiert, haben über den promoviert, habilitiert und zehn Doktor, ehren Doktorwürden, in der Auseinandersetzung mit Beethovens Werk.
Und diese Leute, die müssen natürlich jeden, der sagt, ich mache jetzt hier die zehnte
Sinfonie fertig, der wird dann von denen beurteilt und bewertet und kritisiert und so.
Das haben wir da alles so gemacht.
Weißt du, wer mit dabei war bei dieser Maßnahme mit der KI und der 10. Symphonie?
Die Deutschen Telekom.
Ich weiß, der hat ja bezahlt, ja.
Na super, sollte man lieber Mobilfunkmasten aufstellen und nicht den Beethoven seine Musik wegnehmen.
Das geht leider nicht, wie wir dazu kommen.
Genau, also das ist absehbar, dass wir jetzt dahin kommen werden, so ein Portal zu haben, wo ich sagen kann, mach mir mal ein neues Intro für Logbuch Netzpolitik.
Aber das soll halt so klingen wie, keine Ahnung, Hans Zimmer das machen würde.
Und da ist dann halt wieder die Frage, ist so ein Style überhaupt schützbar? Also es ist sozusagen ein, klingt wie in irgendeiner Form machbar und im übernächsten Schritt hast,
du das natürlich dann auch mit Text to Speech. Also wir werden auch irgendwann aus dieser AI werden auch vollständige Podcasts herausfallen. Und dann gehst du halt auf dein Podcast AI-Portal und sagst,
ich hätte jetzt gerne hier mal eine aktuelle Sendung, wo über Chatkontrolle geredet wird und ich möchte gerne zwei Stimmen haben und die eine klingt so wie Tim und die andere klingt so wie Linus.
Und die sagen dann irgendwie guten Morgen.
Ja, aber okay, das ist ja unser Plan, aus der Nummer hier irgendwann noch mal rauszukommen.
Exit Strategie AI.
So läuft dann die Sendung auch immer weiter und ihr merkt gar nicht mehr, dass wir schon.
Ja, du weißt nicht, an wen sollen wir das hier verkaufen?
Die Metaebene Podcast Verwertungsgesellschaft. Wir haben übrigens, ich hab dir gerade mal rüber geschickt, ein Mainzelmännchen bei.
Längst auf einer Insel sind.
Das ist so cool.
Banksy gemalt von Stable Diffusion und es ist leider nicht so schlecht.
Also das Mainz im Mädchen hat ein bisschen Banksy Style, aber...
Könnte noch ein bisschen meintelmenschiger sein, aber ja, kann man mit ein paar Verfeinerungen dran arbeiten.
Ah ja, genau, das ist übrigens sehr interessant mit diesen ganzen Verfeinungen. Also ich habe jetzt selber nicht so viel damit rumgespielt, ich weiß nicht, ob du das mal gemacht hast.
Es gibt ja so reine Portale wie Dolly, wo OpenAI dahinter steckt.
Dann gibt es Stable Diffusion, ist das ja auch so ein...
Ist das komplett open source eigentlich?
Stable Diffusion? Oder nur Teile? ... und Teile.
Also, ich glaube schon, du kannst es auf jeden Fall komplett so laufen lassen.
Der Code ist irgendwie Python und da musst du halt diese Modelle runterladen. Also, du kannst das, ich würde das jetzt mal, ich weiß nicht in welchem Format jetzt diese Modelle sind.
Modelle wahrscheinlich nicht, aber die Software schon. Irgendwie sowas. Egal, worauf ich hinaus
wollte, ist, es gibt ja dann noch Mid Journey. Und Mid Journey ist ja dann auch nicht nur so eine
Engine, sondern das Ganze spielt sich ja in so einem Discord-Server ab, wo dann halt so diese
Community dabei ist und quasi an diesem Refinement noch mit teilnimmt. Also dann hast du ja sozusagen bei den hochqualitativen Ergebnissen, die du dort erzählen kannst, oft auch wiederum noch so ein
so einen Hive Mind von echten Menschen, die sozusagen ihre Fähigkeit im verfeinern dieser Bilder dort kreativ mit zum Einsatz bringen. Also das ist dann.
Ah ja ja ja.
Sozusagen auch noch mal so ein Skillset der Zukunft ist sozusagen AI Trainer oder AI Jockey zu sein. Du setzt dich einfach drauf auf dieses digitale Pferd und
reitest es einfach mal ordentlich ein und hast halt einfach irgendwann alle Tanzschritte drauf und das ist wirklich irre. Also das kann durchaus noch mal so ein Beruf werden,
von dem man bis vor kurzem noch nicht gedacht hätte, dass es dem mal geben könnte. Einfach,
dort diese Skillset zu haben, mit solchen Werkzeugen umzugehen. Ich meine, so wie es halt eine Fähigkeit ist, keine Ahnung, Photoshop zu benutzen oder mit Illustrator sich irgendwie Grafiken zu bauen oder you name it mit welchem Tool. Und dementsprechend hier nochmal
schwieriger in irgendeiner Form zu beurteilen, wessen Input jetzt hier am Ende auch wirklich,
der entscheidende ist, weil genauso ist natürlich auch das klug formulieren des eigentlichen, also dieser iterative Prozess, mit dem man da rangeht. Tipps irgendwas ein, Stability Fusion, das meiste
ist irgendwie schmierige Bilder mit komischen verzerrten Augen und es sieht meistens auch alles total creepy aus, aber wenn du halt das so ein bisschen kennst und weißt, wie du es formulieren
musst und das dann noch mal durch verschiedene Stufen durchsteckst, ich habe nicht zu viel Zeit damit verbracht, ihr merkt es schon, aber dann kann man eben ganz ordentliche Ergebnisse erzielen.
Und die sind ja dann auch schon wieder eine kreative Leistung, die eben ein Werkzeug verwendet, was selbst sicherlich von anderen profitiert, aber wie viel Prozent bleibt dann da noch
übrig und wie viel kann das verhindern?
Ich kann auf jeden Fall jetzt mehrmals hier mein Stilmännchen bei Banksy malen lassen und ich würde sagen, da hat der ZDF keine Schnitte.
Die Kohle geht an Banksy. In diesem Fall jetzt.
Das stimmt, in dem Fall. Ja, Banksy ist einfach auch bekannter als mein.
Ja, das machen wir aber nicht. Ich glaube, unsere AI-Exkurse sind nur so mäßig interessant.
Simmännchen. Vielleicht sollte man es mit Teletubbies und Banksy probieren, dann sieht es
wahrscheinlich schon wieder anders aus.
Also das Spannende ist, es ist ein schwieriges Problem und deswegen können wir uns darauf
verlassen, dass wir eine ganze Reihe völlig überzogener, total suboptimaler, beknackter,
Lösungsvorschläge dafür finden, hören werden, von denen einer der Schlechtesten dann genommen
wird.
Das wäre jetzt meine allgemeine Prognose dafür.
Ich denke, der größere Teil des Problems oder der erste Aufschlag könnte sein,
dass man sagt, es wird jetzt eben ein Standard geschaffen, ein
technischer Standard, mit dem man eben sagen kann, dieses Material nicht. dann wird man sehen, wie viele davon Gebrauch machen. Dann werden natürlich irgendwelche Getties und also die, die viel Bild haben, werden das anwenden. Die,
die viel Text haben auch. Die, die viel Musik haben ebenfalls. Und dann wird man
schauen, wie viel AI-Lehrmaterial noch übrig bleibt. Und am Ende werden ja die, die viel davon haben, also die, die viel Bild, die, die viel Ton, die, die viel
Text haben, also Verlage, Musikverwertungsgesellschaften und Porno-Seiten, alles andere ist ja vernachlässigbar, werden dann eben,
irgendwelche Kräftemessereien machen, so wie wir es mit YouTube auch gesehen haben.
Aber das wird natürlich dann gerade bei der Musik, bin mir ganz sicher, dass wir das sehen werden,
die Frage ist nur, was kommt dabei raus? Weil gerade in der Musikindustrie, ich meine erinnere
dich an diese Fälle, die wir hier auch besprochen haben, mit diesen ganzen Klagen, mit wer hat jetzt,
hier was kopiert und ist irgendwie so ein Sample dann sozusagen schon lizenzfähig oder nicht. Also das war ja schon bei so eins zu eins Kopien, was weiß ich, Kraftwerk-Samples werden in irgendeinem
Rap-Song verwendet, wo man relativ klar sagen kann, okay, dieser eine Sample, der klingt jetzt mal wirklich genau so wie von dort und wir diskutieren jetzt sozusagen nur darum, ob die Wertschöpfungshöhe
ausreicht, wenn das so und so viele Sekunden Material waren oder nicht, dass dann sozusagen eine Bagatellgrenze entfällt. Aber wenn jetzt sozusagen der Klang, der dabei rauskommt,
nur diesen Charakter hat und in irgendeiner Form daran erinnert, wie das ja in der Musik.
Tausenden Millionenfach täglich passiert, weil alles am Ende eine Inspiration von allem ist und niemand wirklich originär mit irgendeinem neuen Sound herauskommt, dann wird sich das, glaube ich,
gar nicht mehr finden lassen. Ich meine, Komponisten werden dann schon auch sehen, dass das, was so der,
einfache abklatscht ist, sich mit diesen Tools sehr viel einfacher erzeugen lässt.
Ich sag mal so Supermarkt, Lizenz freie Supermarktmelodie, da muss sich dann wahrscheinlich keiner mehr so richtig hinsetzen, sondern da sagst du einfach wirklich der Maschine nur noch, mach mal angenehme Musik für den Supermarkt, den Leute gerne hören.
Ja gut, und dann kommt er.
Es ist die Frage, soll dir angenehm sein oder soll dir dich von oben bis unten mit Werbung
zuballern?
Hallo, haben Sie jetzt schon an der frische Decke? Also meine Prognose ist, am Ende klassische netzpolitische Tragödie, Arschlöcher auf beiden Seiten und für uns nichts zu gewinnen.
So würde ich mir das, der wäre jetzt um meine Prognose, wie das läuft.
Ist auf jeden Fall nicht viel zu gewinnen.
Aber ich will noch mal ein anderes Drosszenario mit auszusprechen, auch auf Gefahr hin, dass wir die Leute wirklich nur auf Ideen bringen.
Aber wir wissen ja, am Ende haben sie trotzdem Leistungsschutzrecht.
Leistungsschutzrecht der Verlage in Bezug auf Textwiederverwendung. So, wenn du jetzt deine AI auf alle Nachrichtenartikel der Welt wirfst.
Um gerade nicht ganz so sicher, was das Ergebnis davon sein sollte. Aber also nehmen wir jetzt mal an, das Problem Text zu verstehen, als solches ist jetzt weitgehend gelöst.
So was wie Chat-GPT, liest sich ja zum Beispiel Programmierer-Webseiten, so Stack Overflow, solche Sachen durch und gibt einem dann manchmal ganz brauchbare, manchmal total unbrauchbare,
wie man in bestimmte Dinge angehen sollte oder versucht, irgendwelche Begriffe zu klären.
Und mal liegt es total goldrichtig und mal liegt es total daneben. Ähnlich könnte man natürlich jetzt mit solchen Dingen versuchen, herauszufinden, wie ist die gesellschaftliche Stimmung?
Welche politischen revolutionären Tendenzen bilden sich ab?
Was lässt sich in irgendeiner Form aus unserer Nachrichtenwelt heraus distillieren, was wir vielleicht so als einfacher Betrachter einzelner Artikel so nicht sehen?
Ist jetzt ein bisschen ins Blaue hinein formuliert. Greift dann da ein Leistungsschutzrecht?
Liefert Deutschland Leopard 2 an die Ukraine.
Genau, sind wir schon so weit jetzt oder müssen wir nochmal darüber diskutieren?
Das ist ja auch irgendwie ein bisschen Neues.
Wir haben noch ein AI-Thema, auf das wir vielleicht jetzt leicht übergehen können. Und zwar, es hat weiterhin mit dem Lehrmaterial zu tun.
Das Lehrmaterial wird in großen Mengen aus dem Internet zusammengekratzt.
Wir sprechen in diesem Fall, fangen an mit Text, also Chat, GPT, machen aber weiter mit Bildern.
Es wird aus großen Mengen zusammengeklaut und dann muss es, ja, also es ist klar, dass es eine Aufbereitung braucht.
Üblicherweise, die zielen natürlich auf kostenlose Aufbereitung ab.
Also jeder Person, die einem Bild so einen Oldtext gibt und eine Bildbeschreibung hinzufügt,
wie das ja seit jeher im HTML auch ein Standard ist zur Ermöglichung der Barrierefreiheit
für Menschen, die Bilder nicht wahrnehmen können oder nicht in Gänze erkennen können. Das ist natürlich immer kostenloses, also technisch ganz gut vorsortiertes kostenloses Lehrmaterial für AI.
Dann gibt es andere Sachen, die müssen vielleicht mal konkret zugefüttert werden. Und dann gibt es aber das Problem, wenn du so ungeprüft große Datenmengen aus dem Internet
nimmst, sei es das Text, sei es das Bilder, da hast du relativ schnell das Problem, dass es nicht jugendfrei ist oder in irgendeiner Form eben auch gewaltverherrlichend, sexuell,
schreckliche Schilderungen, Dinge, die du nicht haben willst. Und das gleiche Problem kennen wir ja auch schon von Facebook, diese Millionen oder Milliarden
die da ihren Beiträge in das Internet schreiben, irgendwie säubern müssen.
Es gibt auch eine schon vor einigen Jahren gelaufene Dokumentation The Cleaners,
die sich damit auseinandersetzt, dass dann eben Menschen in Niedriglohnländern das, was eine AI vorfiltert, noch mal manuell prüfen müssen und sagen müssen,
okay, das muss gelöscht werden oder nicht.
Hatten wir auch letzte Woche mit Khaleesi, hatten wir dann auch heute in Modere.
Habt ihr das schon angesprochen? Ich war mir nämlich nicht sicher, ob das angesprochen wurde oder nicht. Jedenfalls, was macht man? Man outsourcest es nach Kenia, Uganda und Indien,
und lässt es für zwei Dollar die Stunde durch den Mist stochern und die AI erziehen, sie das, was wir nicht wollen, nicht macht. Was ich aber sehr schön oder sehr interessant
fand, war, dass Unternehmen, die das gemacht haben, die kassieren 12,50 Euro die Stunde.
Also die nehmen 10,50 Euro für sich selber, geben zwei den Menschen, die die Arbeit machen.
Und dann kam es aber so, im Februar 2022 wurde beauftragt, diese Unternehmen Bilder zu kategorisieren,
wo dann eben das Thema sexualisierte Gewalt, Morde, Kinder und so weiter zu entfernen.
Dann hat selbst dieses Unternehmen den Vertrag mit OpenAI gekündigt und hat gesagt, das machen wir nicht mehr. Das muten wir unseren Arbeitenden nicht mehr.
Das ist schon auch faszinierend üble Rückseite davon.
Wobei die sich jetzt auch deshalb aufgelöst haben, weil sie jetzt sozusagen in zunehmendem
Maß unter Druck kamen von den Mitarbeitern und sich dort halt entsprechende Gewerkschaften
gebildet haben oder Arbeitvertretungen.
Dann wäre es langsam teuer geworden. Dann machen Sie es lieber anders.
Es bleibt ein unterbetrachteter Teil dieses Phänomens.
Die Diskussionsfolge, die erste war, dass jetzt irgendwie Klausuren an den Universitäten davon geschrieben werden können.
Übrigens, da habe ich einen guten Hinweis bekommen, den ich mal verspätet nachreichen soll.
Darüber gelächelt, habe gesagt, wenn geisteswissenschaftliche Klausurergebnisse nicht mehr zu unterscheiden sind,
dann ist es ein Problem der Geisteswissenschaften. Und habe mich da ein bisschen drüber lustig gemacht.
Mathematik und naturwissenschaftliche Klausuren kann AI schon sehr viel länger.
Das, denke ich, habe ich an der Stelle nicht sinnvoll wiedergegeben und berücksichtigt.
Insofern ist es im Prinzip, dass jetzt eine geisteswissenschaftliche Arbeit oder Hausarbeit oder Klausur von solchen Dingern gemeistert wird,
ist im Prinzip die letzte Hürde und nicht die erste gewesen. Das ist nur mal als späte Einordnung ein paar Folgen her.
Wir haben uns irgendwie so, wie ändert das die Welt?
Aber wir haben uns so wenig Gedanken darüber gemacht, was ist mit denen, die die Materialien dahin kippen und aufarbeiten, haben die Rechte? was ist mit denen, die die aufarbeiten? Haben die ernstzunehmende Löhne oder so?
Das sind auch Aspekte. Alle gucken immer auf die tolle Technologie und erinnert mich so ein bisschen an, um jetzt noch einen sehr geschmacklosen Vergleich zu machen,
die ganze Welt freut sich über das iPhone und man hatte dann da diese,
schrecklichen Bedingungen bei den Zulieferern, wo es ja dann auch sehr viele, die Arbeitsbedingungen jetzt nicht den Standards und Werten entsprachen, die man vielleicht dem
Unternehmen zuordnet. Also es gibt da eine Seite, die auch gesellschaftlich diskutiert und
berücksichtigt werden sollte. Haben wir es zu AI oder wird es noch ein bisschen ein lustiges Bild haben, Tim.
Naja, also man kann da sicherlich noch stundenlang darüber diskutieren.
Ich habe es jetzt ja mit Teletubbies und Banksy probiert, aber ich bin auch nicht weitergekommen.
Also lassen wir das. Kommen wir lieber zu den ganz konkreten klassischen Bedrohungen in Deutschland.
Ja, und zwar, wir wissen ja alle in Deutschland, die größte Bedrohung kommt von Links.
Nicht davon, dass wir mit...
Und von links und von links von links und von links. Also speziell von linken Links. Die sind richtig gefährlich.
Stimmt.
Also Links auf Links sind eine große Gefahr. Und auch das ist ein Thema, was wir hier vor Jahren behandelt haben.
Da ging es um die Webseite links unten, Punkt Indymedia, eine Webseite mit Open Posting,
auf der sich auch unter anderem öfter mal Bekenner schreiben nach irgendwelchen Aktionen
fanden. Und weil das war dann ein ganz großes Thema, dass diese Webseite verboten werden sollte.
Und was haben sie gemacht?
Sie haben das Betreiber-Kollektiv, was jetzt wenig mehr gemacht hat, als eine Webseite zu betreiben und ein bisschen rein zu moderieren, um zu gucken, dass da jetzt nichts Illegales drauf passiert.
Und das eben mit, sagen wir mal, mit best effort gemacht haben. Dann haben sie das Betreiber-Kollektiv zu einer kriminellen Vereinigung erklärt.
Und dann sind auf diese Weise denen halt hergeworden. Absolut überzogen, eine völlig irrsinnige Idee, so etwas zu tun.
Wurde auch zu Recht ausführlich kritisiert. Wir haben Vorträge dazu auf dem Kongress gehabt, die wir noch mal in die Show Notes machen.
Wir haben das hier in der Sendung behandelt. Der Fall hat jetzt viele Jahre später zu einer Hausdurchsuchung bei Radio Dreiecksland geführt.
Radio Dreiecksland ist so ein unabhängiger Radiosender in Freiburg und die hatten,
oh Dreieck, ohne S, und die hatten einen Beitrag veröffentlicht und zwar mit dem Titel.
Dreieckland. Ohne S. Dreieckland.
Linke Medienarbeit ist nicht kriminell. Ermittlungsverfahren nach Indymedia links unten verboten wegen Bildung krimineller Vereinigung eingestellt. Diesen Artikel haben sie veröffentlicht
im Juli 2022, wo sie dann eben sagen, bald fünf Jahre ist der konstruierte Verein Indymedia links unten nun verboten. Gab es ja gar nicht. Die haben einfach gesagt, das wäre einer,
damit sie dann sagen konnten, es ist eine digitale, eine kriminelle Vereinigung und so weiter.
Dann haben Sie diese Kurzmeldung, beenden Sie mit. Im Internet findet sich links unten in die media.org als Archivseite.
Damit endet diese Meldung, wo Sie darauf verlinken, dass es eine Archivseite gibt,
von diesem links unten in die media.org.
Übrigens ist auch unter dieser Webseite erhältlich.
Und das wurde diesem Radiosender nun zur Last gelegt, dass sie auf diese Seite liegen.
Das war's für heute.
Gegen die ein Verbotsverfahren angestrengt wurde, das gescheitert ist. Und dann haben die nichts anderes zu tun, als die Räume dieses Radiosenders und zwei,
Privatwohnungen zu durchsuchen und dabei Datenträger wie Laptops und Smartphones zu beschlagen,
weil die einen Link gesetzt haben.
Fertig absolut. Und ich würde auch davon ausgehen, dass wir diese Linke... Nein, haben wir nicht,
haben wir nicht, liebe Kommissarinnen und Kommissare in Freiburg. Unglaublich, oder? Also auf so ein...
Also man muss sich ja wirklich fragen, was die Intention dahinter ist.
Also, ich meine, denken die jetzt überhaupt nicht ober nach oder ist das einfach pure Absicht?
Also es kommt auf jeden Fall so rüber, als wäre es pure Absicht. Also man weiß gar nicht, was schlimmer ist, dass man ihnen pure Absicht unterstellt oder totale Inkompetenz.
Das ist ja ein totales Dilemma, weil dazwischen scheint es ja irgendwie überhaupt gar kein Angebot zu geben, dass in irgendeiner Form das rational nachvollziehbar machen könnte.
Die wissen doch, dass dieses Radio in dem Sinne nicht auch nur ansatzweise mit dem Thema zu tun hat, was da im Fokus war.
Und was wollen sie dann damit verhindern? Dass Links im Internet gesetzt werden auf so einer Webseite, ist das jetzt an sich verboten auf einmal? Habe ich jetzt noch nichts von mitbekommen.
Ja, das ist vor allem, weil alle Ermittlungsverfahren gegen angeblich beteiligte Personen und auch,
das wegen Bildung einer kriminellen Vereinigung wurden eingestellt. Und dass diese Seite in Anführungszeichen verboten wurde, lag ja daran, oder es war ja
ein juristischer Trick von unserem damaligen Innenminister Thomas de Maizière, weil er wusste, er kann diese Seite, er kann jetzt kein Presseerzeugnis im weitesten Sinn oder eine Internetseite verbieten, die nichts falsch gemacht hat.
Deswegen hat er gesagt, das ist kein Medium, sondern ein Verein. Dieser Verein ist eine kriminelle Vereinigung, deswegen verbiete ich den Verein.
Und in dem Beitrag, wo die sagen, das hat nicht geklappt, diese Strafverfahren haben kein Ergebnis gehabt,
da drin linken sie auf diese Seite. Weil jetzt müsste man, kann man natürlich als juristische Layen sagen,
Aha, das sollte hier verbunden werden.
Die Leute wurden zu einem Verein erklärt, den sie nie gegründet haben. Und die Mitgliedschaft in diesem Verein wurde zum Problem.
Und so weiter und so weiter. Also kann ich ja offenbar auch wieder auf diese Seite linken, weil niemand von denen verurteilt worden.
Ganz im Gegenteil, das letzte Verfahren wurde ergebnislos eingestellt.
Also muss ich doch eigentlich in dem, also muss ich doch in gutem Glauben auch auf die Seite linken können, wenn sie erreichbar ist und ich keinen Statuscode 451 bekomme beim Aufruf.
So. Und dann gehen die hin und sagen, ne ne, das ist ja hier, ihr habt jetzt den Link auf,
eine verbotene Vereinigung gemacht und jetzt argumentiert offenbar diese Staatsanwaltschaft und Polizei, also Polizei Freiburg, Staatsanwaltschaft Karlsruhe argumentieren, dass die Vereinigung
links unten in die Media nach wie vor verboten ist und aufgelöst wurde. Nur es wurde halt niemandem nachgewiesen, Teil dieser Vereinigung zu sein, aber das,
heißt ja trotzdem nicht, dass es nicht verboten ist. Und deswegen haben die jetzt im Prinzip, wäre das so, als hätten sie...
Also die Verfügung des Verbots, der Vereinigung, die nicht existiert und deren Mitgliedschaft niemandem nachgewiesen werden konnte,
die ist immer noch gültig in Wahrnehmung der Polizei Freiburg und Staatsanwaltschaft Karlsruhe.
Und deswegen meinen die, sie müssen ein Pressemedium durchsuchen. Also ich meine, würdest du jetzt links unten in die Medien, was weiß ich mal, mit der.
Es ist schon interessant, dass man was verbieten kann, was man nicht greifen kann.
Also ich meine, wenn sich das nicht in Menschen manifestiert,
Woher weiß man denn überhaupt, also wie ist denn überhaupt definiert, was es ist?
Islamischen Staat-Idioten da verbinden. Die haben auch keinen offiziellen Eintrag im Vereinsregister.
Aber es ist schon irgendwie klar, oder es ist schon irgendwie verständlich, dass man
erwarten würde, dass es ein Straftatbestand, Verstoß gegen ein Vereinigungsverbot, Paragraf,
58 StGB, den deswegen ermitten sie jetzt, weil ein Radiosender, den es da irgendwie,
seit Ewigkeiten gibt.
Also, denen geht es einfach zu gut.
Ja, und könnte sich vielleicht auch auf andere Sachen konzentrieren.
Denen geht es zu gut, aber das wird auch nicht mehr lange so weitergehen.
Insofern kann man auf Besserung hoffen.
Kümmern euch lieber über die Funklöcher, darüber solltet ihr euch mal ein paar Gedanken machen. Das ist ja auch immer noch, es ist ja auch immer noch, es ist ja, es ist ja absurd, ja.
Manchmal weiß ich ja auch nicht so richtig, ob ich mich selbst immer so vollnehme, wenn ich irgendwie sage, ich glaube nicht daran, dass Deutschland dieses Problem mit der Digitalisierung noch jemals gelöst bekommt.
Da geht dann auch so ein kleiner Schock durch mich hindurch.
Nur es gibt relativ wenig Belege dafür, dass es anders kommen wird.
Ja, also das Drama, es ist noch nicht mal wirklich was unbedingt Neues, was wir jetzt verkünden,
aber ich habe es jetzt im Spiegel diese Woche noch mal gelesen. Also Anfang 2021, also ungefähr zwei Jahren, hat der damalige Verkehrsminister Andreas Scheuer,
Da geht es ja schon los, da muss man ja schon lachen.
Hat eine Bundes-GmbH gegründet, und zwar die Mobilfunk-Infrastrukturgesellschaft.
Und die war dafür da, die weißen Flecken, mit anderen Worten,
also weißer Fleck ist da, wo kein einziges Mobilfunknetz funktioniert,
aufzulösen. und findet sich im Spiegel der wunderschöne Satz,
statt das Problem zu lösen, wurde sie selbst zu einem.
Sehr schön. Und zwar, diese MIG, Mobilfunkinfrastrukturgesellschaft,
hat in zwei Jahren nicht einen einzigen Masken gebaut.
Nicht einen einzigen. Die haben auch Schwierigkeiten gehabt, Leute zu finden, die dort arbeiten wollten.
Wir hatten mehrere Geschäftsführerwechsel und mehrere Rüffel des Bundesrechnungsrohres.
Im Oktober 2022, also vor wenigen Monaten, haben Sie den ersten Förderbescheid erstellt. Der erste Bescheid, dass Sie irgendjemandem Fördergeld geben.
Und zwar für einen Standort in einem bayerischen Wandergebiet. Ja, ist in Ordnung, da will man auch Netz haben.
Das ist ja okay.
Da will man auch wandern, wenn es da jetzt gibt.
Und da haben sie gesagt, das ist jetzt ein Meilenstein. Bis dahin, im vergangenen Jahr, 2022, hat diese Bundes GmbH 30 Millionen Euro an Verwaltungskosten verschlungen.
Wie viel Fördergeld war's denn?
30 Millionen Euro Verwaltungskosten.
So. Und weißt du, wie viel Geld die, wie viel von ihrem Fördergeld die ausgegeben hat?
Also das Fördergeld war in Ordnung. 115,4 Millionen Euro. Das hätten die verteilen können.
Da käme die Quote ja hin, dass du sagst, okay, dafür, dass du 115 Millionen Euro verteilst,
musst du 30 Millionen Verwaltungsaufwand haben. Klar. Also kann ich jetzt nicht beurteilen. Ist klar, dass du einen Verwaltungsaufwand hast, um sicherzustellen, dass nicht irgendwelche.
Das ist nicht so schnell geht's. Also ein Prozent...
Ja, dass die, um sicherzustellen, dass die zu schnell gehen. Das haben sie gut gemacht. Weißt du, wie viel die im letzten Jahr ausgegeben haben?
1,2 Millionen Euro wurden an konkrete Projekte gebunden. Um 1,2 Millionen Euro zu verteilen an Milliardenkonzerne, brauchen wir 30 Millionen Euro.
Also ein Prozent.
Und damit ist klar, wir kriegen das nicht hin.
Wir kriegen das nicht hin. Free Money!
Vor allem, was ist denn das bitte für ein Modell? Also man baut eine Bundes-GmbH, eine GmbH.
Sowas macht man ja, damit es effizient ist. GmbH. Kein Amt.
Sondern eine GmbH. Lean, schnelle Entscheidung, Agile. Da kommt einfach die Nachricht rein,
da muss sofort reagiert werden, der Markt braucht das. Was ist deren Aufgabe? Deren Aufgabe ist Fördergelder zu verteilen, damit die Telekom selber ein Mass baut,
wo sie sonst keinen gebaut hätte. Also erstens, warum kann die Telekom sich diese Förderanträge nicht selber aus der Nase rausziehen? Zweitens, warum überhaupt so ein Konstrukt?
Wieso baut nicht einfach der Staat, davon bin ich nämlich eigentlich ausgegangen, selbst diese Standorte und betreibt sie auch selbst und vermietet sie einfach an,
die anderen Betreiber, die dort keine Abdeckung haben. Natürlich gepaart mit.
Ja.
Eine Verpflichtung endlich auch mal anders abzudecken als das bisher ist,
weil wir haben ja immer noch diese merkwürdige Regelung. In Deutschland musst du nicht das Land abdecken, sondern du musst, ich weiß nicht wie viel Prozent,
das sind 99, 98 Prozent aller der Bevölkerung, der Haushalte, also da wo
die Leute wohnen, da musst du ihnen Mobilfunk geben.
Kleiner Hinweis an die Politik, mobil ist, wenn ich nicht zu Hause bin.
Ja und der große, also was das, weißt du, was die weißen Flecken bleiben? Autobahnen und Bahnstrecken.
Da wurde wirklich mal gebrauchen, Göttes.
Das zitieren die ja auch übrigens in dem Artikel nochmal, dass der Altmaier, damals Wirtschaftsminister, sagte, ja, also er würde jetzt, also er sitzt ja viel dann im Auto, fährt da durch die Gegend,
und er würde sich jetzt nicht mehr mit internationalen Kollegen nicht mehr im Auto telefonieren, weil die Verbindungsabbrüche so peinlich sind.
Ich bin froh, dass der Zug überhaupt fährt, weil wenn das GSMR ausfällt, dann fährt ja überhaupt kein Zug.
Aber es ist ohnehin, es ist in Deutschland erklärter Wunsch.
Wir wissen, wir haben im Moment drei Mobilfunknetze, ein Viertes kommt jetzt wieder in den Markt. Telefonica O2 hat E plus gekauft. Der deutsche Regulierer oder die deutsche Politik hat sich entschieden, wir möchten vier Mobilfunknetze haben.
Deutsche Telekom, Telefonica O2, Vodafone und 1&1. Jetzt geht 1&1 in den Markt und muss ein neues Mobilfunknetz bauen. Und zwar komplett.
Die sollen konkurrieren. Wir möchten vier Mobilfunknetze haben in Deutschland. Das bedeutet aber auch, es werden fucking vier gebaut.
Vier Unternehmen müssen die finanzielle Last auf sich nehmen,
ein Mobilfunknetz zu bauen. Und zwar jedes einzelne Unternehmen selber. Weil die sich eben nicht Dinge teilen dürfen. Kleine Einschränkung.
1&1 darf jetzt für begrenzte Zeit Roaming im Telefonikernetz machen,
damit sie, während sie ihr eigenes Netz bauen, schon mal Abdeckung haben.
Das wird ihnen erlaubt.
So wie das mit E-Plus am Anfang auch war.
Das war's für heute.
Genau, das ist ja auch sinnvoll. Aber überleg dir mal, warum wollen wir viermal diese Infrastruktur bauen?
Ich kann verstehen, dass man sagt, wir wollen sie nicht nur einmal haben. Dass man sagt, wir wollen zwei Unabhängige haben. In Ordnung.
Einen dritten kann ich dann schon schwer verstehen und einen vierten sowieso nicht mehr.
Ich bin nicht gegen die Erstellung eines vierten Mobilfunknetzes, ganz im Gegenteil, man will ja Konkurrenz haben. Aber doch bitte in der Leistung und nicht in der...
Es ist ja überhaupt gar kein Problem, viele andere Länder machen das ja. Insbesondere übrigens auch in den Bereichen, die vielleicht nicht so bevölkerungsdicht sind.
Dass man sagt, okay, hier erkennen wir an, das ist nicht ökonomisch sinnvoll. Hier baut der Staat eine Infrastruktur hin und diese Infrastruktur in die roaming dann alle anderen Netze.
Von mir aus ist das in Ordnung, genau das, was du gerade vorgeschlagen hast.
Es ist alles möglich, aber wir machen es nicht. Stattdessen nehmen wir den Milliarden weg, damit sie funken dürfen und wundern uns dann, dass sie zu teuer sind.
Das ist ja der andere Witz. haben jetzt irgendwie, hier zitiere ich jetzt mal den Telefoniker Deutschlandchef Markus Haas.
Der sagt, in den vergangenen zwei Jahrzehnten hat die Mobilfunkbranche allein für Frequenzen 70
Milliarden Euro an den Bund bezahlt. Also 70 Milliarden Euro. Und er sagt, hätten wir das in die Infrastruktur investiert, hätten wir heute Glasfaser in allen Haushalten und flächendeckende,
5G-Versorgung. Er hatte natürlich recht, natürlich.
Und gleichzeitig ist die Bundesnetzagentur oder ist der Staat ja jetzt den Mobilfunkanbietern bei 5G entgegengekommen. Die mussten insgesamt 6,5 Milliarden haben die jetzt geboten für die Frequenzen.
Das können die aber jetzt über die Zeit abstottern.
Wahnsinn!
Was sie vorher auch gemacht haben, weil sie ja eh Kredite aufgenommen haben.
Ja, natürlich. Aber absoluter Irrsinn. Währenddessen muss man auch sagen.
Also das ist alles Unsinn.
Also 1&1 ist gerade stark verzögert in seinem Aufbau des neuen Netzes. Die wollten zum Jahresende,
1000 Funktürme stehen haben, haben aber bisher laut Medienberichten nur eine niedrige,
einschläge Anzahl erklären, dass aber, also sagen, du hast ja quasi, du mietest dir ja diese Stellen nicht selber.
Eine niedrige, einstellige Anzahl mit anderen Worten, sie haben noch nicht mal ein Prozent hinbekommen.
Im Gegensatz zu dieser Bundes GmbH, die hat immerhin schon mal 1% ihrer Fördertöpfe.
Nein, auch nicht. Ja, ganz knapp 1%. Jetzt muss man sagen, wie kommst du auf die Dächer?
Irgendwie weitergereicht.
Da gibt es natürlich, also einen Funkturmstandort zu betreiben ist längst ein Geschäftsmodell. Da gibt es also Unternehmen, denen gehören, die haben quasi diese Antennenmast, Stromanschluss,
19 Zoll Rack oder so was auf einem Dach. Und die vermieten dann da diesen Rackspace im Prinzip und diesen Antennenstandort an die anderen Unternehmen.
Das heißt, theoretisch ist es, also potentiell kann das sehr schnell skalieren.
Also es wäre denkbar, dass eins und eins, wenn sie jetzt genug Leute los schicken.
Und quasi der Anlernprozess, der technische Anbindungsprozess einer neuen Zelle,
Wenn Sie den Streamline und genug Leute haben, die dann auf die Dächer klettern und die Dinger
da dran schrauben, dann könnte es denen potentiell sehr schnell gelingen, diese 1000 Antennen
hochzuziehen. Eben unter der Annahme, dass sie den Prozess des Festschraubens schnell genug hinkriegen.
Deswegen, laut diesem Artikel zeigt eben 1&1 auch auf das Unternehmen Vantage Towers und,
sagen, bei denen haben wir hunderte Masten bestellt, die haben die nicht fertig gekriegt, also ist deren Schuld. Vantage Towers sagt, wir haben eine Geheimhaltungsvereinbarung mit 1&1, deswegen äußern wir uns nicht. Irgendetwas stimmt da nicht, aber auf jeden Fall kann man sagen,
in diesem Fall scheint das Problem ja bei denen zu liegen. Und 1&1 hat ja auch ein Interesse,
diese Antennenstandorte hinzukriegen, dass sich so was mal verzögert kann sein, um einige Zeit, aber es besteht jetzt Hoffnung, dass sie dann eben sehr zügig skalieren können.
Aber auch natürlich 1000 Antennenstandorte ist unglaublich wenig bei 5G. Die bauen ja ein 5G-Netz.
5G, hohe Bandbreite, hohe Frequenz, daher geringe Reichweite, das heißt, mit denen wird sie nicht so weit kommen. Also die werden noch sehr viele mehr
tausend Antennen brauchen.
Ja, aber staatliche Rolle in dem Bereich...
Ich kann es wirklich nicht verstehen.
Also ich kann es, ich verstehe es nicht.
Erstmal, wie kann man, und ich hab's vorhin schonmal angesprochen, aber man muss sich
einfach mal klarmachen, diese Verpflichtung Haushalte zu versorgen, ist bei Mobilfunk einfach Unsinn.
Macht einfach 100% der Fläche als Vorgabe und jedes Prozent, was ihr nicht abgedeckt habt, kostet euch so und so 4 Milliarden pro Jahr.
Fertig. Was glaubst du, wie schnell das geht?
Die Bundesnetzagentur zieht ja jetzt im...
Also das Problem ist ja jetzt, dass sie nicht... Sie können nicht nachträglich die Regeln ändern. Das könnte man höchstens mal bei 6G machen in ein paar Jahren.
Ja Leute, ich meine, das hat man jetzt bei LTE verpasst, das hat man jetzt bei 5G verpasst. Wie lange will man das jetzt noch verpassen? Das ist ja einfach ein,
Ich meine, erinnere dich damals, als sie diese 3G-Lizenzen verkauft haben, diese riesigen Milliardenbeträge, die du angesprochen hast, war ja vor allem bei dieser 3G-Auktion, da sind sie ja total steil gegangen, haben richtig viel Kohle eingenommen.
Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was die Zahl war, aber es war viel. Und die Reaktion des, also das, was man ja UMTS nannte, und dann gab es ja diesen schönen
Kommentar von Hans Eichel, damals der Finanzminister der Bundesrepublik Deutschland, er hat in
Was er meint, zu OMTS?
Hätte ich eine Abkürzung für?
Genau, das war die unerwarteten Mehreinnahmen zur Tilgung von Staatsschulden.
Das war sozusagen die einzige Perspektive da drin.
Es hat sich gefreut, dass da so ein bisschen Kohle reinkam und so weiter, aber dass das Geld halt wirklich mal zum Aufbau von Infrastruktur verwendet wird,
das war so überhaupt gar kein Thema. Warum?
Weil, und das meine ich wirklich, weil die Politik in Deutschland, Das hat sich noch nicht ausreichend geändert.
Es wird zwar jetzt viel geredet darüber, aber nicht entsprechend gehandelt. Die Bedeutung der digitalen Infrastruktur ist komplett komplett unterschätzt worden.
Niemand verstand auch nur im Ansatz, wozu das gut sein soll. Da kamen Leute an und gesagt, wir würden hier gerne Internet machen und so weiter.
Und Mobilfunk und so. Ja, mach mal so. Hauptsache irgendwie im Auto funktioniert das ja schon. wenn der Rest jetzt auch noch will, dann gibt uns einfach mal Geld dafür, passt das schon irgendwie. Aber wie wichtig das für die Wirtschaft ist und wie wichtig das auch für die Gesellschaft am Ende ist
und die Konkurrenzfähigkeit dieses Standortes und besonders der Landbevölkerung, hat einfach keiner gesehen.
Im Vergleich dazu muss man sich immer mal wieder vor Augen halten, wie sackschnell das ging damals mit Kabelfernsehen. Das hat ein paar Jahre gedauert und zack, zack, zack war dieses ganze Land umgegraben
Und in jeder Hütte stand Kabelfernsehen.
Das ging überall, weil da war ja Privatfernsehen dahinter und da werden dann irgendwie politische Botschaften vermittelt potenziell.
Deswegen muss das Ganze halt auch durchgezogen werden.
Und wie schön, dass der Postminister damals irgendwie auch noch eine Kabelfirma hatte, irgendwie die ganzen Kabel verkauft hat.
Jetzt müssen wir noch mal gucken auf die weißen Flecken.
Die Bundesnetzagentur plant jetzt zu sagen, wir verhängen ein Bußgeld von bis zu 50.000 Euro pro Standort.
Denn die hatten quasi den Mobilfunkunternehmen gesagt, ihr müsst in diesen weißen Flecken,
Es darf keine Gegenden geben, in denen kein Handynetz eine Übertragung von 100 Megabit,
pro Sekunde schafft. Das ist ein weißer Fleck. Und dann haben Sie den Netzen gesagt, jedes Netz muss jetzt 167 eigene Standorte in so
einer Gegend bauen. Also auch hier wieder schon falsch. Statt zu sagen, ihr müsst alle zusammen, was wäre
das dann, 501, wenn ich das jetzt richtig gerechnet habe, solche Standorte bauen und.
Die versorgen. Gemeinsam muss jetzt jeder wieder eigene. Wettkampf. 167, so keine.
Wurde davon hat 86 gebaut, Telefonica 61, die Telekom 38. Und da sagt eben, dass die Bundesnetzagentur
so für jeden Fehlenden erwägen, wie jetzt, 50.000 Euro Strafe. Jetzt sagen die Netzbetreiber, ja wir kommen ja aber voran, Telekom sagt, wir bauen ja gerade 14 weitere. Dann sagt er,
da seid ihr schon bei 52 von 115. Und dass an den übrigen fehlenden Standorten zu einem großen.
Ha ha ha ha ha!
Teil keine Funklöcher bestehen, sondern dort gäbe es ja eine Grundversorgung. Also es gibt,
Breitbankempfang, aber eben nicht 100 MBit. Und dann sagen sie, das finde ich auch geil, Außerdem verweisen die Firmen darauf, dass sie eine staatliche Liste mit den betroffenen Gegenden
zu spät bekommen hätten, als wenn die nicht wüssten, wo sie keinen Empfang haben. Weißt du, Misse, der Staat hat uns gar nicht gesagt, wo unser Netz nicht funktioniert. Und dann,
Dann gibt es eben ein paar Tut, gut das stimmt, ein paar Tut, dann haben sie natürlich die wenigen vollbekloppten, die das für einen Standortvorteil halten, wenn es da kein Mobilfunknetz
gibt. Da gibt es nämlich kein Grundstückseigentümer, sei bereit ein Stück Land für einen Funkmast zu vermieten.
Und in Naturschutzgebieten ist es ebenfalls schwierig. Aber das ist doch auch ein Witz, diesen Artikel lesen jetzt Menschen, die wenn sie Glück haben,
gerade Internet haben. Und die tun irgendwie so, als würden wir alle in Naturschutzgebieten sitzen. Unglaublich, ja.
Telefone könnten langsam mal anfangen, selber irgendwie diese unterversorgten Bereiche zu melden.
Ist doch überhaupt kein Geheimnis, das weiß man doch. Das weiß man ganz klar.
Es gibt bei Mobilfunknetzen die Frequenzplaner. Das ist jetzt, die bauen nicht irgendwo mal aufs gerate Wohl eine Antenne hin.
Die wissen ganz genau, und sie müssen ja auch zum Beispiel, wenn du diese Netze, diese Dinger hast, dann misst du die ja auch mal aus. Du stellst ja nicht die Antenne hin und fährst nach Hause.
Du machst dir ja Gedanken darüber, mit welcher Frequenz du jetzt ballerst. Hast du die Frequenz? Nutzen andere?
Die Frequenzplanung ist ein Thema und es ist relativ klar, wo die Funklöcher sind. Die sehen ja zum Beispiel auch die ganzen Failed-Handovers, wenn ihnen das Auto aus
der Zelle rausfährt und nicht irgendwo anders hinspringt.
Denen ist völlig klar, wo sie Abdeckungen haben.
Ich brauche eine Warn-App, die mich davor warnt, dass ich jetzt in ein unterversorgtes Gebiet fahre.
Ja gut, dann mach dir ne App, die sagt, wenn du die Grenze zur Bundesrepublik Deutschland,
überfährst. Ist auch nicht schwer.
Das ist nicht schwer.
Das gibt es ja schon, man kriegt immer eine SMS, wenn man schon draußen ist.
Ja, du kennst doch, wenn du in ein anderes Land kommst, kriegst du ja so ne SMS Willkommen
in Polen oder so. Könnte man auch sagen, Achtung Deutschland, Achtung unterversorgter Sektor. Wenn was passiert, kann es sein, dass Sie keine Hilfe rufen können.
Ab jetzt gibt es wieder Netz. Ja, also können wir da einen Antrag stellen.
Es regt nicht ohne SIM-Karte.
Ja, für 5G, ich glaube, waren die 6,5 Milliarden.
Das sind 6,5 Milliarden, die diese Unternehmen verdienen müssen und für die sie schon mal kein Netz bauen.
Das ist das einzige, was hinter der Summe stehen muss. Okay, Tim, wir regen uns nur auf.
Aber man braucht ab und zu mal so ein LMP-Klassik.
Ja, auf jeden Fall. Kommen wir zu der anderen Warn-App. Genau. Corona-Warn-App gibt es noch. Übrigens gibt es noch. Gibt es jetzt auch neu in Version 3.0. Wurde vor ein paar Tagen released.
Corona war ein...
Und es gab viele Releases in dieser ganzen Zeit. Also ich muss sagen, die ganze Entwicklung dieser
App ist weitergelaufen. Es war ja auch ganz ordentlich finanziert, aber es ist auch was,
getan worden. Es sind immer wieder Features eingebaut worden, es sind immer wieder Anpassungen
vorgenommen worden. Ich finde, dass die App auch an sich gereift ist. Es war schon eigentlich immer
gut bedienbar und Statistiken, also viel auch reingekommen, was am Anfang noch wünschenswert erschien oder was andere Länder gemacht haben. So nach und nach ist das alles eingearbeitet worden.
Jetzt mit der neuen Version gibt es aber eine grundsätzliche Änderung, nämlich diese Hotline.
Bei der man anrufen konnte, wenn es automatisiert mit dem Absenden des eigenen Tests nicht funktioniert hat. Die wird jetzt demnächst eingestellt, weil das ist auch ein ziemlich,
teurer Punkt und man hat jetzt wohl auch eingesehen, dass das jetzt einfach nicht mehr Not tut. Die pandemische Lage hat sich geändert und dem wird halt dadurch jetzt Rechnung getragen in der App,
dass man künftig selbst entscheiden kann, wo sich das nicht mehr von irgendeiner Stelle oder einem
System absinken lassen muss, selbst entscheiden kann, wann man sozusagen andere Leute warnt, wenn man selbst meint positiv zu sein, weil man eben einen entsprechenden Selbsttest gemacht hat.
Das ist ja so ein Feature, was von Anfang an auch diskutiert wurde und was, glaube ich, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, in der österreichischen App zumindest am Anfang
auch mit drin war oder geplant war, ich habe es nicht mehr so im Einzelnen verfolgt,
und was ja so eine Debatte war. Missbrauch, kann man jetzt Leute irgendwie verrückt machen und es war ja solange auch ein Thema, als dass du dann eben diese Isolierungspflicht hattest etc.
Und das scheint sich jetzt dahingehend geändert zu haben, dass man das so machen kann. Trotzdem wird es eine Beschränkung darin geben, wie das stattfinden kann und zwar eine zeitliche Beschränkung. Man kann das glaube ich nur einmal innerhalb von drei Monaten machen pro Device.
Okay, aber jetzt muss ich erst mal sagen, dass diese Hotline jetzt erst abgestellt wird,
empfinde ich schon als schwerwiegendes Versagen. Dass es sie überhaupt noch gab, finde ich eine Katastrophe.
Und eigentlich hätte es sie nie wirklich geben sollen. Wenn man eine sinnvolle digitale Anbindung der Teststationen gehabt hätte, wäre das sinnvoll gewesen, als das noch eine Rolle spielte.
Du hast sinnvolle digitale Anbindung gesagt.
Im Sinne von, in dem Moment, wo du den Test machst, erteilst du die Erlaubnis zur Warnung.
Das kann man ja schon abbilden.
Es ist kein besonders komplexer Prozess. Jetzt muss man auch sagen, der ist aber im Zweifelsfall nicht notwendigerweise an der
Telekom gescheitert, sondern auch an den ganzen windigen Testbuden, die ja häufig einfach
nur von Leuten aus dem Boden gestampft wurden, die nichts besseres zu tun hatten.
Ja, die Testboote, ich weiß nicht, ich würde das nicht so ernst formulieren, weil,
am Ende ist das alles ja etwas gewesen, was neu war und was vor allem mit dem Zusammenspiel von Menschen und Ängsten und Nöten zu tun hat.
Dass da eine ganze Menge schiefgehen kann auf den einzelnen Wegen, Formulare nicht richtig benutzt, verwendet etc., sozusagen dieses Melden hätten unterbrechen können und ja auch unterbrochen haben.
Dann so ein Vorback zu haben zu sagen, okay jetzt machen wir das aber hier einfach über die Hotline, das fand ich schon in Ordnung. Wie lange die jetzt noch hätte laufen sollen und in welchem Ausmaße, darüber kann man diskutieren.
Gut, aber offiziell ist ja der Schabernack jetzt erst vielleicht bald vorbei, sagt Rosten.
Ja, okay, ich glaube, da will ich jetzt gar nicht ins Detail gehen, weil Drosten sagt
nicht unbedingt, der Schabernack ist vorbei, obwohl er sagt, wir werden wahrscheinlich nicht mehr mit Wellen konfrontiert werden.
Die Pandemie als solche, sozusagen, es geht halt jetzt in eine andere Phase über und faktisch ist es halt schon längst in eine andere Phase übergegangen in der Art und Weise,
wie wir da mittlerweile in der Mehrheit mit umgehen und das ist das, was du meinst mit,
Ich wundere dich, dass das diese Hotline nun gegeben hat. Wie auch immer.
Ja, und ich würde auch sagen, es wird jetzt Zeit, die Corona-Warn-App dann mal langsam
zu beenden. Wenn wir nicht mehr mit Wellen zu tun haben und wenn wir im Prinzip keinen
Wert mehr darin sehen, konkret Infektionsketten zurückzuverfolgen und all diese Dinge, wenn
wir jetzt irgendwie sagen, wir haben jetzt eine Krankheit mehr, die so ein bisschen rumgeht
heute noch die Meldung, Corona spielt auch auf den Intensivstationen keine Rolle mehr,
oder eine immer geringere Rolle, dann haben wir jetzt eben diese endemische Phase mit einem neuen
Krankheitserreger und da muss man sich irgendwann fragen, welchen Beitrag leistet die Corona-Warn-App noch und welchen Wert, wie viel Geld wollen wir dafür ausgeben? Und ich denke, das kommt jetzt
jetzt hier eben langsam zu einem Ende. Und das ist ja auch erst mal gut, oder?
Also ich würde jetzt nicht meinen, dass die App jetzt sofort abgeschaltet werden muss,
weil die schadet erstmal nicht so und man kann sich ja auch noch nicht total sicher sein,
dass nicht morgen schon wieder, weißt du, also ich denke, das braucht auch so ein bisschen seine Zeit und der Zeitpunkt wird kommen, wo sich dann alle in gewisser Hinsicht auch einig sind. Ich meine,
du kennst das aus den Diskussionen. Aber du erfährst das ja sicherlich in deinem Umfeld auch auf die andere Art und Weise, dass es Gruppen gibt, die, sagen wir mal, eine andere.
Ich finde, wir können jetzt mal eine Payment-App daraus machen.
Wahrnehmung haben bezüglich der aktuellen Situation und der Notwendigkeit von Maßnahmen und Schutzmaßnahmen etc. als andere Gruppen. Und das war natürlich von Anfang an so, aber
verschiebt sich. Und in dem Moment, wo so ein echter gefühlter Mehrheitskonsens da ist, mit dem das jetzt nicht mehr die Rolle spielt, das ist dann wahrscheinlich auch der richtige Moment, die App zu sunsetten.
Es kann aber auch sein, dass das sozusagen von Apple und Google irgendwann einfach durchgeführt wird, indem sie einfach diesen Service abschalten und sagen, das brauchen wir jetzt nicht mehr. Das war's dann.
Ja, und du darfst ja nicht vergessen, das bringt immer alles nur, was die Leute mitmachen.
Und in dem Moment, wo das Mitspielen abnimmt, das ist natürlich erstens so, wenn die Leute die ganze Waren-App nicht mehr so ernst nehmen, die ganze Pandemie nicht mehr so ernst nehmen
und außerdem der Meldeprozess doch sehr bürokratisch ist, dann führt das natürlich zu so einem Selbstverstärkter machen nicht mehr mit Effekt. Und das ist ja das, dem wird hier glaube ich auch gerade begegnet, in dem gesagt wird, alles klar, jetzt kannst du
selbst testen, du kannst so eine Auslösung machen.
Und dass du innerhalb von drei Monaten nicht noch mal noch ein zweites Mal an
Corona erkrankt bist, ist glaube ich auch klar. Und die Leute gehen, dass du jetzt
die Wirtschaft oder das öffentliche Leben lahmlegst durch durch Massenwarnungen, ist diese Gefahr jetzt auch, denke ich mal, durch die neue Phase jetzt.
Geht das ja auch nicht mit der Corona-Warn-App.
Also du kannst nur Massen warnen, wenn du auch Massen begegnet bist.
Und wenn du dann wirklich positiv bist, dann...
Ja, also ich würde sagen, insgesamt, dass das wird schon ganz...
Ja, dass man jetzt mit einem Selbsttest warnen kann. Ich glaube, das habe ich auch
schon vor längerer Zeit mal gefordert. Oder zumindest, dass man jetzt mit einem Schnelltest mal vernünftig, unbürokratisch warnen kann und so. Aber ja, Okay, es gibt eine Weiterentwicklung, sehr schön.
Ansonsten würde ich jetzt sagen, auch dass diese Telefon-Hotline da jetzt mal abgestellt wird, war sicherlich auch mal langsam an der Zeit.
Und hoffen wir, dass die App dann irgendwann jetzt auch, ja, hoffen wir,
weil es keinen Anlass gibt, die App über diesen Funktionsumfang noch weiter zu entwickeln.
Gibt es noch eine andere App, die man nicht mehr weiterentwickeln muss? Ohne Vorwarnung.
Ja, andere Apps, nicht nur eine, diverse Apps wurden jetzt gesunsettet, aber nicht von
Apple oder Google, sondern von Twitter. Oder wahrscheinlich Elon Musk, also was vielleicht nicht alle unbedingt wussten, aber der Dienst,
Twitter, der gut, das wissen wahrscheinlich alle, dass es da so eine API gibt, mit dem man halt diese ganzen Tweets hin und her wirft, normalerweise spricht die normale Twitter-App,
auf den einzelnen Plattformen diese API und ein paar ausgewählte Kunden sicherlich auch.
Aber es gab eben auch einzelne unabhängige Party-Apps, die auch über diese Twitter-API Tweets absetzen und lesen lassen konnten. Mit eingeschränkten Funktionsumfangs war nicht immer.
Alle Features dort verfügbar. Also Polls zum Beispiel konnte man nur in der Original-Twitter-App oder auf der Webseite machen. Neuere Features wie diese Lesezeichen etc. das war alles nicht drin.
Aber wer, wie wir, diese Apps benutzt hat, war von etwas anderem verschont, nämlich von der ganzen,
Werbung und noch viel wichtiger von dieser algorithmischen Timeline, die einem einfach,
irgendwas immer wieder in die Timeline reinschmeißt und es nicht unbedingt immer klar wird, warum das
jetzt gerade aufgetaucht ist, anstatt einfach diese ganz klassische ich kriege einfach alle Tweets von allen Leuten, denen ich folge, eine Fertigliste zu bekommen.
Ja, ganz normale chronologische Timeline, fertig. Ohne Werbung, das ist super.
Und ja, Twitter hat natürlich im klassischen Geschmacksvollstil die API abgeschaltet, fertig. Dann gab es, dann beschwerten sich die Twitter-Nutzerinnen, die Apps wie Twitterific, Tweetbot und wie sie alle heißen,
verwendet haben, beschwerten sich dann und Tabbots, die Bande, die Tweetbot,
programmiert hat, schrieb dann auch so, na ja, wir wissen nichts, wir haben bei Twitter gefragt, mal gucken, ob uns jemand antwortet und haben dann eben, ich,
glaube, viele Tage später wurde dann von Twitter gesagt, Twitter Dev, wir,
Wir erzwingen jetzt unsere schon lange geltenden API-Regeln.
Das kann sein, dass deswegen einige Apps nicht funktionieren.
Tun so, als gäbe es die jetzt sagen, hat die Tapbots Leute so.
Wir haben das hier seit über zehn Jahren gemacht.
Wir haben immer uns an alle API-Regeln gehalten. Wenn es irgendeine Regel gibt, die wir nicht eingehalten haben, würden wir sehr gerne darauf hingewiesen werden und der Regel entsprechen.
Aber wir müssen wissen, was das ist. Ihr wisst doch, wie ihr uns erreicht. Geiler Style, ne?
Ja, da gab es auch irgendeine, das glaube ich auch, ich weiß nicht, was sie da bezahlt haben.
Vor allem ist es auch keine kostenlose Nutzung gewesen. Die Firmen mussten auch dafür bezahlen.
Den genauen Betrag kenne ich auch nicht. Weiß auch gar nicht, ob das so öffentlich ist, oder es da eine Preisliste in dem Sinne gibt. Aber der Betrag, den man halt an Tweetbot oder so an seinen Client zahlt für eine Subscription, wenn die das gemacht haben,
wurde eben teilweise dann eben auch Twitter zugeführt. Also es ist auch nicht so, dass sie damit jetzt nichts verdient hätten. Also besonders übel ist halt die Art und Weise, wie sie das jetzt wieder gemacht haben, auch wenn keiner so richtig mehr überrascht war.
Wenn du jetzt mal nur bei Tabbots schaust, am 12. Januar releasen sie eine neue Version.
Am 13. Januar sagen sie, es gibt irgendwelche Probleme. Am 14. Januar sagen sie, wir haben immer noch nichts gehört.
Am 17. Januar gibt es eben die Meldung von Twitter Dev. Das heißt, vier Tage haben die da rumgestanden. Die hatten bis zum letzten Moment gerade noch ein neues Release. Und jetzt können sie das Ding abwickeln. Diese App wurde getötet, wofür die Leute angestellt hatten.
Und sagen jetzt, na ja, ihr könnt uns ja schon mal auf tabbots.social folgen und wir bauen
gerade eine neue App für Mastodon.
Wir haben es über zwölf Jahre gemacht und jetzt können Sie Ihre App töten. Say goodbye to Tweetbot schreiben noch so, ja, diejenigen von euch, die irgendwie eine,
Subscription bei uns hatten, die kriegen die Kohle.
Das canceln wir jetzt alles über Apple.
Also was für ein, also wie Asi, ne?
Und es ging ja nicht nur Tweetbot so, sondern es gab ja noch diverse andere Clients, insbesondere
Twitterific muss man an der Stelle erwähnen, was ja in gewisser Hinsicht so ein bisschen
der Client war, der unter anderem den Begriff Tweet geboren hat.
Also, dass so ein Posting Tweet heißt, das ist die Erfindung dieser App und dass dann immer so ein Vögelchen-Sound abgespielt wird, wenn man was veröffentlicht und so weiter. viel der Innovation kam über die Apps und sehr viel dieser Innovation.
Jetzt ist auf jeden Fall Innovation. Aber stimmt, bei Twitter ist es tatsächlich
Innovation. Das Ding hat sich ja über Jahre nicht weiterentwickelt.
Ja, also und alles kam da über die User und sowohl User als auch Third Party wird halt mit Füßen getreten. Ich muss auch sagen, das ist jetzt so ein bisschen der,
Punkt, wo ich dann halt auch langsam darüber nachdenke, den Spaß jetzt mal zu beenden. Es ist halt leider so, dass Twitter nach wie vor
eine hervorragende Nachrichtenquelle ist für bestimmte Dinge, die so an anderer Stelle noch nicht sich manifestiert hat. Das mag sich ändern, aber noch ist es nicht soweit.
Ja, es ist, tatsächlich ist das, also kann man übrigens auch bei allen Mastodon-Fans,
eben auch sehen, dass sie auch immer sehr darauf erpicht sind zu betonen, dass Mastodon eben nicht Twitter ist und entsprechend ist eben leider auch der der der Schaden oder das Problem, das für uns jetzt entsteht.
Also auch übrigens in Vorbereitung dieser Sendung.
Natürlich ist Twitter da eine wichtige Quelle für uns,
die richtigen Nachrichten früh zu bekommen, die guten Perspektiven darauf früh zu lesen
oder auch die schlechten Perspektiven darauf früh zu lesen. Oder wird jetzt halt gerade kaputt gemacht.
Wir haben auch unsere Mastodon-Accounts verlinkt und wir werden uns da auch öfter zeigen.
Schön und gut, aber lasst uns vielleicht unser Trauer, dass uns da trotzdem jetzt was fehlt
und kaputt gemacht wurde, was notwendig für uns war an vielen Stellen.
Das ist das einzige soziale Netzwerk, das ich genutzt habe.
Ja, das Einzige für mich, was mich immer Sinn ergeben hat.
Ich habe jetzt mal diese, also notgedrungen nutze ich jetzt hier die Standard-Twitter-App. Die ist hier völlig unbrauchbar, völlig unbenutzbar.
Und also allein dadurch ist es schon kaputt.
Also nicht nur, dass dieses Kaputtmachen, dieser Style jetzt irgendwie völlig daneben ist, sondern auch, dass es jetzt wirklich nicht mehr funktioniert. Tage gebraucht, um zu merken, dass die jetzt irgendwie, wenn ich auf meine normale Timeline
gehe, dann eben dieses hier für dich und ich dachte immer, wer sind diese Menschen? Nie gesehen.
Das sind irgendwelche Leute, wo Twitter meint, die könnten mich interessieren. Den folge ich aber nicht.
Ich habe quasi absichtlich oder unabsichtlich die Entscheidung getroffen, diesen Menschen
nicht zu folgen. Oder ich meine, ist auch ganz nett, vielleicht meine Empfehlung, aber das kann doch nicht die Standardsicht sein. Ich habe tagelang, habe ich diese App aufgemacht, habe gedacht, passiert hier nichts?
Wo sind die Tweets hin? Sind echt schon alle weg?
Haben die schon alle rüber gemacht, nicht der Letzte. Aber ja, war tatsächlich einfach nur ein,
ein anderer Standardview, den du dann immer die... Mann, Mann, Mann, Mann, Mann.
Also es gibt noch einen Tipp, wie man Twitter trotzdem noch halbwegs brauchbar benutzen kann,
auch mit der normalen Twitter-App.
Und zwar musst du einfach deine Followerships, also die Accounts, denen du zu einem bestimmten Thema folgst,
packst du in eine Liste. Das hast du vielleicht eh schon teilweise getan, aber man... Und dann guckst du dir die Liste an und die ist halt frei von dem ganzen anderen Scheiß.
Und dann folgt, dann guckst du dir die Liste an.
Das heißt, über Listen kann man nach wie vor sozusagen das machen die normale Timeline einfach komplett ignorieren. Das tue ich schon längere Zeit. Das heißt.
...
Ich habe so, was weiß ich hier, meine Ukraine Timeline etc., kann ich darüber verfolgen. Das geht natürlich mit dieser Twitter-App auch nicht so gut wie mit Tweetbot, weil der dann nicht irgendwie nachlädt und wenn dann die App nicht lief, dann verlierst du dann halt irgendwie die Nachrichten und dann kannst du dann auch nicht hinterher scrollen. Das ist ganz furchtbar und,
schlimm so, aber so kann man zumindest erst mal so den widerlichsten Teil ausblenden und das sozusagen noch so Rest benutzen. Mal schauen, also ich meine mir liegen natürlich auch alle in den
Ohren mit Mastodon und Pipapo und warum denn nicht da. Gut, habe ich alles schon tausendmal gehört,
ich habe meinen Mastodon-Account auch schon seit 2017, ist jetzt nicht so, dass ich das irgendwie noch nicht entdeckt hätte oder so. Mir lag es einfach nicht, auf mehreren Netzwerken,
parallel zu diskutieren und meine Quellenpflege zu betreiben, um dann am Ende nicht mehr zu wissen, was wo ist. Also dass man sozusagen so einen Knotenpunkt hat, an dem sich dann
alles macht und wo ja quasi auch immer alle da waren, also alle in Anführungsstrichen alle.
So das fällt halt jetzt so ein bisschen weg einerseits dadurch, dass es nicht mehr so gut benutzbar ist und andererseits, dass es eben unter Umständen auch wirklich jetzt eine.
Abwanderungsbewegung gibt und ich würde mal sagen so eine Art Balkanisierung natürlich auch. Das gibt ja viele Leute, die jetzt von diesem Masternetzwerk auch dadurch angetan sind,
dass es eben nicht der globale Chat ist, sondern dass es sich eben in lokaleren Communities abspielt. Aber bin ich noch nicht so ganz überzeugt von, dass das so
der der Weg ist. Würden jetzt alle Leute, die nicht derzeit auf Twitter folgen beziehungsweise sich in irgendwelchen Listen haben, auf Mastodon überwechseln,
was einige schon getan haben, aber beileibe auch noch nicht alle, dann sähe das
natürlich auch schon anders aus. Trotzdem ist das Netzwerk anders. bestimmte Features, die Twitter hat, fehlen da halt. Es hat andere Features, die Twitter fehlen, gar
keine Frage, aber es ist jetzt nicht ein One-to-One Replacement, sondern man muss dann im Prinzip
seine ganze Kommunikationskultur auch nochmal überarbeiten. Das steht wahrscheinlich eh an,
das werde ich auch tun, aber ich hätte es mir auch gerne erspart.
Ja, Depp.
Der einzige Typ, den ich finden konnte, der Elon Musk noch irgendwie Genie zutraut, ist,
Frank Thelen. Kennste Frank Thelen? Das ist ein Depp. Das ist der einzige Depp, der noch nicht gemerkt hat, dass Elon Musk ein Depp ist.
Oh Gott.
Ist das nicht der Typ, der seine eigenen Startups auch alle in den Sand gesetzt hat?
Er hat alles in den Sand gesetzt. Der verbrennt den ganzen Tag Kohle von anderen Leuten.
Warum werden solche Leute gefeiert? Warum, welche solche Leute überhaupt interviewt?
Das ist der Loser vor dem Herrn, der hat diesen 10x-Forder gemacht.
Der hatte halt irgendwie so ein kleines Vorzeichenproblem gehabt und hat nicht den Einsatz verzehnfacht,
sondern durch 10 dividiert. Und dann hat er einfach noch einen gemacht, damit die Leute das Restgeld in den anderen
werfen. Also ich weiß auch nicht, warum den irgendjemand für voll nimmt, aber wenn ich
das richtig verstanden habe, tritt der in irgendeiner RTL-Sendung auf oder so. Und weil
wir ja wissen, dass Leute, die bei RTL sind, ungefähr zu den seriösesten Gehörn, die
wir im Land haben, wird der gefragt.
Du meinst wahrscheinlich die Höhle der Löwen.
Ja genau, das, was immer mit Dieter Bohlen oder so im Spam ist. Ja genau, da ist der.
Jaja, genau. Das ist halt so was wie Trump gemacht hat.
Übrigens hat auch Elon Musk offenbar mit seinen seit Twitter Anschaffungen 200 Milliarden an privatem Reichtum vernichtet.
Also sein eigener privater Reichtum. Und damit mehr als jeder Mensch jemals.
Also er hat die größte Vernichtung von privaten Reichtum vorgenommen, die je ein Mensch auf diesem Planeten vorgenommen hat.
Frank Thelen. Du meinst Elon Musk. Du meinst durch die Tesla Aktien.
Nee, Frank Thelen ist da kleines Licht.
Aber Elon Musk, ja. Frank Thelen, ey.
Ich weiß nicht, er hat auf jeden Fall mehr privates, also er hat mehr privates, privaten,
Reichtum in Luft aufgelöst als jeder andere Mensch vorher.
Ja, ja, ja, Slow Clap.
Immerhin noch ein Rekord, ein 1000er dieser Maske.
Absoluter Slow Clap der Tür.
Okay, haben wir noch ein Thema? Ja, eins hatten wir noch. Ah ja, das müssen wir kurz der
Vollständigkeit erzählen, und zwar Arne Schönbumm, der ehemalige Präsident des Bundesamtes für Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik,
der dann in Folge einer Böhmermann-Sendung geschasst wurde. Wir haben den Phänomenbereich
ja hier durchaus behandelt und ausreichend gewürdigt. Sie haben es jetzt geschafft,
wie sie loswerden. Und zwar wird er zum Präsidenten der Bundesakademie für öffentliche Verwaltung.
Und das ist eine Behörde mit Sitz in Köln-Brühl oder so was. Und dort verfügt er jetzt in
Zukunft über 55 Mitarbeiter und ein Budget von dreieinhalb Millionen Euro. Als er noch
beim BSI war, waren das 1700 Mitarbeiterinnen und 217 Millionen Euro Haushaltsmittel. Das,
heißt, er ist jetzt sehr stark eingeschränkt in dem, was er da macht. Und sie haben quasi vorher, damit sie ihn dahin verschieben konnten, haben sie quasi die Besoldung für den Präsidenten,
dieser noch nie von irgendjemandem wahrgenommenen Bundesakademie von B5 auf B8 hochgeschoben, damit der Schönbom jetzt keinen Gehaltsverlust erleidet. Und das nimmt ihm im Zweifelsfall die,
Möglichkeiten, sich dagegen zu wehren, weil das eben eine Versetzung ist, die grundsätzlich erstmal allgemein möglich ist, mit ihm nicht mit Gehaltseinschränkungen einhergeht.
Und ja, faszinierend. Da wird halt einfach mal eine neue Stelle geupgradet
von ein paar tausend Euro Jahresgehalt, um den da loszuwerden.
Ja, was sollen sie machen? Ich meine, sie hatten ja nichts Konkretes vorzuwerfen, was jetzt sozusagen eine Degradierung gerechtfertigt hätte.
Und der hätte sich da locker sowieso gleich wieder reingeklagt in den Besoldungsbereich.
Und von daher war das natürlich so eine Finte, die sie dann einfach ziehen mussten. So, ich meine, viel Spaß er da jetzt haben wird bei dieser... Dann kriegt man richtig einen Stopp ins Maul, wenn man nur den Titel ausspricht. Bundesakademie für öffentliche Verwaltung.
Ja, ich würde davon ausgehen, dass er sich jetzt irgendwie etwas Neues wuckt,
wahrscheinlich, oder einfach sagt, alles klar Leute, ich genieße jetzt meinen frühen Ruhestand. Der alte Präsident von Alexander Eisvogel soll nach Bonn,
wechseln und soll das Beschaffungsamt des Innenministeriums leiten. Und die Person, die das geleitet hat, Ruth Brandt, die wird Präsidentin des
Statistischen Bundesamtes in Wiesbaden und damit Bundeswahlleiterin. Die einzige Stelle, die noch umbesetzt bleibt, ist die des BSI-Chefs. So, jetzt gucken wir mal. B9,
B8, Bundesstraße 8, Besoldung. Was kriegt man denn da?
Grundgehalt 11.717,33 Euro. Das ist nicht wenig, aber auch nicht viel.
Also kommt drauf an, aus welcher Perspektive man das sieht, aber man leidet nicht Hunger.
Ja, aber dafür leidet man nicht Hunger, je nachdem, wie viel man isst oder von welcher Qualität.
Da muss man schon wirklich sehr viel essen. Also da kannst du schon jeden Tag im Restaurant verhungern.
Ich glaube aber auch, dass diese ganzen Besoldungsgruppen, die haben so eingebaute Erhöhungen, oder? Da ist doch irgendwie...
Ja, und dann ist da auch viel Rentenanspruch mit dabei und Pipapo, ich kenne mich da nicht wirklich aus, aber ich glaube schlecht geht es den Leuten nicht.
Ne, ne, geht ja nicht schlecht, aber gut, ich mein, man muss halt für Nancy Felser arbeiten und über,
dir zu und.
In der Politik musst du immer gerade für irgendjemand arbeiten, der dir nicht passt.
Na gut, ist jetzt auch nicht nur in der Politik so. Okay, kommen wir.
Nee, generell so.
Langsam zu den Terminen. Hast du da so eine Melodie für uns?
Eine Frühjahrsmelodie? Habe ich natürlich.
Ja, du musst dich entschuldigen.
Ja, wir müssen uns entschuldigen, weil ich habe ein bisschen Scheiße gebaut, mal. Das Problem war, dass du zwar schon alles ganz säuberlich vorbereitet hast,
aber dann ja nicht die Sendung mit mir machen konntest und dann habe ich in einem
anderen Dokument mit der Khaleesi gewurstelt und nicht mehr in dem anderen
Dokument, in dem ersten Dokument nachgeschaut. Also ist es uns sozusagen nicht gelungen, hier noch rechtzeitig eine Veranstaltung im X-Hain anzusagen, die am...
Wann? Gestern. Bar. As we speak am 22. Naja, tut uns leid, kommt nicht wieder vor, aber
ihr könnt generell mal ins X-Hain gehen, das ist nämlich ganz toll, das ist ein schöner Hacker-Space,
in Berlin. Friedrichshain, da gibt es dann montags zum Beispiel immer so einen Tag, der offene Tür, ich hab das fast schon gesagt, wie heißt das, so ein offener, offener, offener Montag, genau,
Genau, da kann man schön hacken und da sind coole Leute und überhaupt. Alles ganz toll.
Was wir aber... Genau, den kann ich Ihnen aber noch verlinken.
Das war's für heute.
Den Kalender haben wir verlinkt.
Aber wir haben ja noch was anderes, was wir noch ankündigen können, was gerade noch so funktioniert.
Und zwar, 24. und 25. Februar ist wieder der Winterkongress der Digitalen Gesellschaft Schweiz. Ohne www.winterkongress.ch könnt ihr das Programm finden.
Keynote, 30 Vorträge, diskordische Lesestunde als Ausgang. Wie immer in der Schweiz, wir haben es hier regelmäßig angekündigt, findet jetzt endlich mal wieder statt.
Und dann sind wir rechtzeitig in der Ankündigung. Es wird nämlich wieder einen Easter Hack geben.
Das ist die Osterveranstaltung aus dem Kreise des Chaos Computer Clubs,
die nun viele viele Male nicht hat stattfinden können. Ihr wisst schon warum auch die erste, glaube ich, die ausgefallen ist und jetzt aber dann wohl endlich stattfinden wird.
Und zwar halt um Ostern herum, vom 7. April bis zum 10. April in Hamburg im Kampnagel.
Und das wird stattfinden, aber jetzt ist gerade noch die Zeit, wo man auch Talks einreichen kann. Deswegen erwähnen wir das so früh.
Der CFP ist draußen. Klickt einfach mal auf den Link bei uns in den Show Notes, falls ihr was kluges beizutragen habt, dann könnte das ja vielleicht dort Realität werden.
Mehr haben wir dazu nicht zu sagen, glaube ich. Dann sagen wir da jetzt auch nicht mehr zu.
Dann ist alles gesagt. Das muss ja auch mal gesagt werden.
Dann ist die Sendung jetzt zu Ende.
Woran merkt man jetzt eigentlich, dass diese Sendung noch nicht von einer AI erstellt wurde?
Ich weiß nicht, dass ich zu oft R sage oder...
Das ist sehr einfach replizierbar. Ich glaube, sowas kriegt ihr sofort raus. Das ist die Spontanität, das ist die Kreativität, das Unerwartete, das Besondere, das was aus
allen Ritzen quillt, das Persönliche, das Unreproduzierbare, das was es nur im Original gibt.
Nur das. Das macht es aus.
Eat this, machine learning!
Uns kriegt ihr nicht kopiert.
Glaube, das dauert jetzt nicht lange, bis irgendjemand irgendein AI-Ding nimmt und uns,
erstens in irgendein Textgenerator wirft und zweitens von JetGBT. Also da bin ich mir relativ
sicher, dass wir relativ bald ein Ding ins Knie kriegen. Etienne, weißt du, was wir überhaupt nicht erzählt haben? Und zum Glück fällt es mir jetzt noch ein. Wir haben ein Telegramm bekommen.
Ja, schau hoch!
Wir haben eines der letzten Telegramme bekommen. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es Telegramme noch gibt.
Ja, also ein Telegramm.
Wusste die Deutsche Post auch nicht. Wahrscheinlich bis jemand reinkam und sagte, ey, Telegramm. Und die sagten so, was? Scheiße, müssen wir anbieten. Oder?
Ich weiß gar nicht, hast du in deinem Leben überhaupt jemals schon mal ein Telegramm bekommen?
Hab ich doch gerade gesagt, Tim, wir haben ein Telegramm bekommen. Das war jetzt das...
Nee, ich meine, hast du bis dahin jemals schon mal in deinem Leben einen Telegramm bekommen oder hast du schon mal eins versendet?
Nein.
Auch nicht. Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher. Lass mich nochmal kurz nachdenken.
Irgendwas war mal in meinem Leben mit einem Telegramm, aber ich weiß nicht mehr, ob das an mich ging.
Ich habe es, glaube ich, nicht versendet. Aber vielleicht bilde ich mir das jetzt auch ein.
Aber das Telegram war irgendwie, ja, das ist so eine Kommunikationsmethode, die war, jeder kannte sie.
Aber kaum einer hat sie wahrscheinlich wirklich benutzt. Aber irgendjemand muss es ja benutzt haben.
Ja, ja. Und du hast halt deinen Text diktiert und der wurde dann ausgedruckt und dann wurde.
Sind hafteuer und irgendwie auch per Zeichen oder so abgerechnet.
Dann wirklich vor Ort persönlich zugestellt. Das ist wirklich irre. Ja, und wir haben aber
jetzt noch eins bekommen.
Und das haben die gemacht, indem die dann bei der Poststation in der Nähe angerufen haben und gesagt haben, ein berittener Boote zu Prittlauf oder was.
Auf jeden Fall kam das bei mir an per Post und da steht guten Morgen Linus.
Ich bin meines Erachtens 184 oder 184 Stell.
Guten Morgen Tim, deutsche Post stellt Telegram ein, hat länger gehalten als DEMail und kostet nur 1,84. Frohes neues Ianto aus Hannover. Vielen Dank. Ganz toll.
Ach so, 1,84, ja stimmt, kostet nur ein Telegramm, hält länger. Ach so, DEMail kostet nur ein
84 von deemail. Was kostet denn ein deemail? Was hat man denn da ausgerechnet?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Ich glaube, er meint, also das habe ich auch nicht. Die Rechnung habe ich nicht ganz verstanden, was eine D-Mail... Ach doch, natürlich! Wir haben doch die...
Ja, natürlich, wir haben irgendwann mal ausgerechnet, wie viele Millionen, die für D-Mail ausgegeben haben und wie viel am Tag versendet wurden.
Und wie viel wirklich verschickt wurden? Weißt du die Zahl noch?
Nee. Aber man kann einfach gucken, was ein Telegram kostet.
Das muss 84 mal so viel gewesen sein.
Und 84 mal so viel ist eine Demaille. Ist ja relativ einfach.
Naja, das ist jetzt bestimmt schon 404 oder 451 vielleicht sogar auch.
Telegram ist kostenlos.
Diese Information ist aus rechtlichen Gründen nicht mehr recherchierbar.
Posttelegramm. Boah, uiuiuiui. Bis 160 Zeichen, 12,57 Euro mit Schmuckblatt 16,67. Wie war.
War kein Schmuckblatt dabei, war die Sparversion.
Kein Schmuckblatt dabei? Was ist das denn für ein billiges Telegramm? Hat es denn über.
Mal vieren.
160 Zeichen? Wahrscheinlich nicht, oder?
Das muss ja nicht in einen Tweet passen. 1055,88 Euro wären das dann für die E-Mail.
Ja, kommt hin.
Hier, wie die Bemittlung eines Telegramms geschah, in drei Stufen aufgeben.
Der Absender schickte entweder einen Boten zum Post- bzw. Telegrafenamt oder diktierte seinen Text und die Empfängeradresse einem Beamten persönlich am Schalter.
Für Glückwünsche konnte man ab den 1920er Jahren künstlerisch gestaltete Schmuckblatt-Telegramme an den Empfänger übertragen. Okay, war ja kein Glückwunsch. Insofern ist es in Ordnung, braucht kein Schmuckblatt.
Ebenfalls ab den 90er Jahren telefonisch aufgegeben werden.
Bezahlt wurde entweder im Amt, per Telefonrechnung oder per Münzeinwurf am öffentlichen Fernsprecher.
Das war alles Blütezeit und so weiter.
Dann wird es übermittelt. Die Texte wurden im Post- bzw. mit der Morse-Taste später über die Tastatur eines Typendrucktelegrafen oder Fernschreiber,
das ist wahrscheinlich Telex, eingegeben oder über eine direkte elektronische Leitung zu einem Post-
beziehungsweise Telegrafenamt in der Nähe des Empfängers übermittelt. In Städten mit mehreren
Postämtern wurde das Aufgeben von Telefons, vor Verboten, später Telefonschreiber in Großstadt
mit der Rohrpost zu zentralen Telegrafenämtern befördert. Telegramm zustellen. Im Empfängeramt wurde der Text vom Morse-Schreiber per Hand in ein Formular übertragen.
Bei Hörempfang wurde die Nachricht von Telegrafenbeamten direkt in das Formular eingetragen.
Zustellung erfolgte durch Telegram-Boten, meist innerhalb von zwei bis vier Stunden nach Aufgabe,
anfangs per Fuß, später per Fahrrad und ab den 1920er-Jahren per Motorrad.
Wie kam der Bote mit Motorrad, Tim?
Ich hab's nur im Briefkasten gehabt.
Wie im Brief.
Also es hat jetzt keiner an der Tür geklingelt.
Ich meine, wenn schon Telegram, dann kann man es ja auch gleich singen.
Ich stelle mir gerade vor, wie dann dieser Typ, der dann irgendwie, also ich würde mal
davon ausgehen, dass die Post seit mehreren Jahren keine Telegram-Boten mehr eingestellt hat.
Das heißt, er war wahrscheinlich ein hochbetagter Beamter, der das seit 20 Jahren nichts mehr zu tun hatte.
Und dann kommen die Postwörter und die Leute so, Kalle, schon wieder Telegramm.
Dann musste der jetzt noch die ganzen Telegramme verteilen, die Leute darüber informieren, dass es keine Telegramme mehr gibt.
Ja, fand ich auf jeden Fall sehr schön, dass wir ein Telegramm erhalten haben. Einen schönen Gruß und einen schönen Dank dafür auf jeden Fall. Hätten wir eigentlich unter Feedback haben sollen, aber die Idee war es auch wert.
Und wenn das Postpaket irgendwann mal zu Ende ist, dann könnt ihr uns Geschenke schicken.
Ach ja, Telekommunikationsromantik, man ist es schon echt interessant, aber siehst du mal, welchen Aufwand Twitter so treiben muss, um so 160 Zeichen durch die Gegend zu schicken.
Pferde, Rohrpost, Motorräder, alles nur für deine Tweets.
Ich meine, das ist wirklich, klingelt so alt, wenn ich das sage, aber so durch dieses Internet hat sich einfach mal alles geändert. hat und wie viel spezialisierte Technologie es gab, um so einzelne Kommunikationsformen zu
ermöglichen, die also vollkommen separat voneinander teilweise existierten. Auch so Telex und so etwas, das war dann eben schon so wirklich der Fernschreiber, das war dann wirklich so der
Real-Time-Kanal. Also ich hatte selber keinen Telex-Anschluss, aber man hat sowas dann schon noch mal gesehen bei dem einen oder anderen Unternehmen, weil das halt einfach eine,
Möglichkeit war schnell zu kommunizieren. Und dann Schritt für Schritt ging das dann über die Zeit alles langsam in diesen digitalen Diensten auf. Aber es hat eben auch lange gedauert. Und jetzt 2023 ist dann auch mal das Telegramm weg. Wie lang so ein Scheiß hält.
170 Jahre. Also wenn du überlegst, was ist... klar, wenn du vor 170 Jahren eine Echtzeitbotschaft
vermitteln wollte, hat das eben tatsächlich noch größeren Aufwand benötigt.
Ja und diese Nähe ist, diese globale Nähe, es gibt diese Selbstverständlichkeit,
der Kommunikation, die ist halt doch dann wirklich noch sehr, sehr neu. Also ich weiß noch so in den
90ern war ja auch so dieses mit den USA kommunizieren. Das war dann auch schwierig. Weil was,
was, was, also wie wolltest du dich denn mit so Unternehmen austauschen? Also es gab zwar dann schon so die allerersten Systeme, so wie CompuServe, aber das hatte natürlich in Deutschland noch so,
recht keine Verbreitung. Also hieß es da anrufen, richtige Uhrzeit finden oder Brief schreiben.
Also alles hat sich komplett auf den Kopf gestellt und wir sehen ja was wir davon haben.
Alle werden verrückt.
Gut, Leute, dann wünschen wir euch viel Spaß und dann bis zum nächsten Mal.
Ja, stimmt.
Alright.
Da hin tschau tschau.